Wait, where am I?
Oh, there I am!
There I am!
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Another day.
Another day of Marvel Rivals.
Yippee!
God!
I'm sorry to not mean to sound depressed.
Oh my god.
Another day of 10, like, late night Marvel Rivals hours.
If I could, I would stream at a decent time for grinding.
I would love to do that.
Today was actually not because I was a Plan Z today.
It was because I actually was doing work stuff.
I was actually being productive.
I was so productive today.
My gosh, New Year, new me everybody.
I cleaned my room.
I had three trash bags that I cleaned up on.
And I threw those trash bags out.
I cleaned my bathroom.
I, like, I actually ordered groceries yesterday night.
Which means I received them today.
Um, and then, um, sorry.
Sorry, immersion.
A little bit of an immersion break right there.
And, um, and then so I actually, my fridge is now stocked up.
I vacuumed.
I answered messages.
Um, I incurred some late fees because I was late on some stuff.
But I didn't.
I apologize.
I even said I'm very sorry.
I do have a crippling addiction to Marvel Rivals right now.
I am so very sorry.
I, I'm so like, I will pay extra because you waited.
I am so sorry.
I'm, I'm trying to become a normal human being now.
Um, but I still have a crippling addiction to Marvel Rivals.
But that's okay because if I get top 500 today, I will be a little bit better.
I think like the closer I get to top 500, the more normal I'm becoming.
Like I'm actually slowly like regaining my sensibilities the closer I get to top 500.
Because like, I ordered groceries today.
I got groceries today because I'm finally eternity rank.
So like, I feel, I feel more and more normal the closer we get to the goal.
Um, uh, Poe, thank you for your one sub.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for the 200 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Killstrike, thank you for the $50 donation.
I really appreciate it.
So for once, I will warm up one game.
I heard Conquest is a really good like warm-up mode also to level up accounts.
But I also heard Conquest is like infested with bots right now from people who are leveling up their accounts so that they can sell it.
Sell it to people for smurfing.
So, um, so yeah, we'll see how it goes.
Yeah, Conquest apparently has a lot of smurfs, bots, hackers, and everything.
Because it's the fastest way to level up an account right now.
I've been on a Psylocke obsession lately.
Whenever I have to like, um, play in low elo, I just play Psylocke because it's so easy.
I'm gonna say that, and then like, I'm gonna get absolutely shit on in this game mode, um, as Psylocke.
Of course, I would like, I would be like, haha, I do so well off-stream playing Psylocke in low- in the lower lobbies.
And then, um, and I say that, and then I'm gonna get absolutely fucking destroyed in the- on stream.
Because this always happens to me.
I always get destroyed on- whenever I like, feel proud of myself, I get destroyed on stream.
Where the fuck are people?
Where the fuck, please?
Oh my go- Okay.
Okay, yep, there we- there it hap- there it goes.
I- I had a feeling that was gonna happen, guys.
Where the fuck are people?
What is he do- is he just beating up the- Oh shit, I was just gonna say, is he literally just beating up the clones?
What the fuck?
Like, okay.
Alright, Conquest is a lot harder than Ex- Conquest is literally just DPS players absolutely shitting on me.
Um.
I like how this is my warm-up.
Alright, there we go.
This is my warm-up, not playing support.
Who the fu- what are you doing, Gru?
Why would you do this to yourself?
What the fuck?
God, I wanna squish a spider so badly.
Like, why are you playing tank on a DPS game mode?
Like, a support would make more sense.
Oh god.
Yay.
Oh, I need heals.
Heals, please.
Oh my god.
I wanna fucking squish a spider.
I hate Spider-Man players.
I-
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Where's the support when you need one?
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Woo,
goodbye.
What is he gonna do?
Fucking kill our shar- oh, he killed our shark.
Yay, he actually killed our shark, guys.
He did it.
Alright.
I'm done with this game mode.
Oh my god, I can't even leave.
I can't even leave this mode.
I - Hate is a strong word.
I absolutely hate spiders now.
I don't care if they're good for the environment.
This game has made me realize like, they don't deserve to live.
They really don't.
Oh my- No!
He flung me out there!
Alright.
Poor spiders.
Sharks too.
Fuck sharks as well.
Let's justify my hate.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
Hello- Oh my god, he just hits- He hits us?
Sharks did nothing wrong.
Oh yeah, explain Jeff.
Explain Jeff.
Jesus Christ, why are you Thor?
What the fuck?
Get me out, get me out.
No, and also raccoons.
No, fuck raccoons too.
You know what?
Okay, I shouldn't say it.
Tell me about all the animals in this world, I guess.
At this point.
Jesus Chri- You know what?
Fuck this.
I don't think I'm gonna kill anybody.
Where did they all just go?
Where did they all go?
Where did everybody go?
They all ran.
I'll reclaim these, just in case.
Guys, please, grab the funny orbs.
Please everybody, grab the funny orbs.
Why do you hate raccoons?
Because I hate one tricks.
And rocket raccoon support one tricks are absolutely terrible to have in game.
In high elo.
Because there's no point.
Okay, I won't do one more game of Psylocke.
That wasn't fun.
That...
Slime, thank you for the $10.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, the closer you get, the more you take care of yourself.
But the question is, what happens when you finally do reach top 500?
When I finally reach it, I basically...
I just stop existing in this game.
No, are you fucking kidding me?
Please!
Why are you playing your lord Psylocke in quick play?
I'm fucking... Okay, I'm gonna...
Last match you might face... Oh my god, this is quick play.
That was literally the only reason.
I need to... I'm gonna look you up on tracker right now.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need to know what your rank is right now.
I need to know what your fucking rank is.
J-V-S-T-V-I-O-L J-V-S-T-V-I-O-L-E T-T Okay.
I need to find you.
I'm finding you on Marvel Rivals right now.
You better have a public profile.
You better fucking...
Oh my god.
I literally queued up just to play Psylocke.
Why the fuck would I...
Oh my god, Marvel Rivals tracker.
They can't wait for me.
They have... Whoa, wait.
I'm fucking... I got you.
I got you.
You're the only diamond three.
Get your... Oh my god.
No one... Oh my god.
I fucking got you.
We don't even need a tank.
I... How petty can you be?
Very petty.
I literally only queued up quick play so I can play Psylocke.
I have important matters...
things to do.
I...
Like, grind rank.
I feel attacked.
It's okay.
It's not you.
You're not... You're not just Violet.
I literally doxxed this guy's fucking rank profile live on... It's not even doxxing.
It's like public information, guys.
It's...
His profile is not private.
That means I can look up his gamer profiling.
Is it truly doxxing if his profile is not private?
Is it truly live on stream?
Guys, I think like Marvel Rivals made me a hater.
I don't know yet though.
I don't know yet, guys.
But like, I don't know.
Lowkey made me a hater.
You don't understand!
All I wanted to do was play Psylocke on stream.
I don't care about anything else.
I...
It just awakened me in it.
I just wanted to play Psylocke in quick play.
Like, I literally could just have queued rank right now.
I could have just queued rank, guys, but here I am.
Not playing rank.
Here I am.
Doxxing me.
Guys, you don't understand.
I could have been doing it.
I could have been playing support rank right now.
I literally could have been doing that.
What iteration did I come to?
My hate arc.
You're in my hater arc right now.
God, I fucking hate you.
The newspaper was right.
He is a fucking menace to society.
My villain arc.
Alright, come on.
How you Lord hella, like, get out.
Alright, fucking goodbye.
You know what?
Fuck you guys.
That's right, you cease to exist now.
That's fucking right.
I refuse to let you exist.
This is my home.
Jesus, that's embarrassing for you.
Come on.
Get over here.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, you respawn?
Your shield has a cooldown.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I'm just trying to get through this quick play session.
I literally only play quick play to play because I wanted to play fucking Psylocke, but here we are playing Oh my god.
Playing Hella instead because I don't want to get this game over with.
And the only way to get this game over with is to play Hella.
Real Hella hours.
Oh my god, you're so embarrassing.
Get off, Cloak.
Don't be so... Don't embarrass the support players.
Alright.
Waiting until the shield is gone.
Ooh, that hurt.
The fuck are you doing, Rocket?
Oh my god!
They actually want to win!
You went double support and a double tank in fucking quick play?
We don't even have a singular tank!
What's wrong with you?
What's actually...
I can't believe it.
They really want to win.
We don't even have a tank.
We don't even have a singular tank in our team.
Oh, that's fine.
That's nice.
The toxic.
Get this stranger off my fucking team.
That's right, I'm gonna fly to you.
Okay, I should not flute to you.
That's fine.
That's right.
Now what you gonna do?
Nothing!
Oh my god.
Please.
I just need like one more heal.
That's fine.
Get out of here.
We don't need a tank.
Get...
Get out!
Nope,
I'm still alive.
Where's the karma?
No karma.
Just MVP.
Just hella uninstall Please!
I wanted to play Psylocke!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Bro, I was barely fucking around.
I wasn't even trying to.
This is the fourth time I've ever played Hella in my life.
I can't believe it.
That was...
That was the fourth time I've ever...
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
God, bro.
Oh my god.
Fucking quick play, man.
Why?
Exactly!
Why are you so serious in quick play?
I'm only angry because I couldn't play.
I couldn't play Psylocke in quick play.
I literally just wanted to play Psylocke.
You know what?
Okay, let's see.
Are they ready?
No, okay.
Guys, I can play.
I'm going to play Psylocke once.
Guys.
Guys, I just want to play Psylocke once and then...
And then...
And then we give you a break.
Really, that's all I want?
Bro, I can't believe our team with no tanks won that.
Like, I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
Save, thank you for tier one.
Save slime, inspector.
Thank you for tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, now I can finally play Psylocke.
I don't know, Psylocke's like super fun.
I remember when I first tried to play Psylocke, um...
I didn't really enjoy it because I didn't, I did not understand how to play her.
But like, right now, like, now that I understand her mechanics, she's really, really fun to play.
Oh my god, we're finally getting our one Psylocke team.
I won't be surprised if I get to play Psylocke and I do absolutely fucking terrible.
I never, I never get to do well on stream.
I can be like absolutely fucking cracked off stream.
And then when it's on stream hours, it's like, oh, here's me tripping and falling, everybody.
No, fuck Black Panther, I swear to god, I...
There's only, like, like, two people that I know that's really, really good at Black Panther and high ELO.
And then they just get target banned because they're just too good.
They just, they just get target banned because they're just too good.
All right, whoa, they're playing up.
Wow, that's, that's new.
All right, this group does, actually, this group doesn't know what he's doing.
This group does, definitely does not know what he's doing though.
Okay, I'm gonna go flank now.
I flank.
I farmed a little bit of ult.
Now I flank.
Oh my god, they're healing each other!
That's illegal!
My other support barely fucking heals me sometimes!
Like, hey!
That's not fair!
The other support healing each other and, fuck, that's actually not fair!
That's...
What, what fucking magical world is this?
Where they actually...
Bro, I'm so... I'm a hater now.
Now you're a hater, Doki!
All I'm saying is that it's absolutely crazy that they're getting babysat so hard.
Like, I never had that privilege in ranked.
I rarely, if ever, get that privilege.
I'm so sad.
There you go.
Oh my god, get out of my lobby.
That's fucking right!
Heal and ult!
That's literally against the rules.
That's fucking right.
Go heal and ult.
Oh my god.
Easy.
How dare they have fun...
If I can't have fun, play support?
Nobody can.
It's just...
It's how it goes.
Woah!
What's wrong with you?
What's wrong?
Bro, they actually chased me.
That's fine.
I'm fine with that.
I should've juked him.
I didn't think he would actually...
You know, I thought he would think I'd go backwards, but then he...
I don't know.
He was like she's definitely gonna go forward and he was right.
He was so right.
Don't worry, I got you.
There you go.
You're welcome.
I did something no other DPS would do.
Peel.
It's like an actual privilege.
You're welcome.
Oh!
I'm just gonna get rid of these clones.
Cause he's right here.
And he doesn't know.
Okay.
He still...
That's awkward.
That's actually awkward but...
Whoops!
I woke him up.
I did something that everybody hates.
There we go.
No situational awareness.
That's actually crazy.
Seeing that look.
He literally just walked in a straight line.
Like, not caring over the fact that, you know, I exist.
There we go.
Do they have lamp?
Oh, they're stupid.
His teammate's stupid.
That's fine.
Woo!
Oh my god!
I need help!
Stop!
Teammate walking away from the lamp.
Yeah, I was just like, yep.
That's fine.
A lot of people don't know I play with a low-key player.
Especially in quick play.
Which is pretty funny.
Yay!
Let me stand here real quick.
Alright.
Easiest game of my life.
We have five minutes left?
Holy shit.
What is the other team doing?
I'm just gonna stay on cart.
So fuck this.
Let's get this over with.
Please.
The Hawkeye is right there.
Oh my god.
I will help.
Oh, get this magic away from me.
I shall stop helping.
One fear.
Alright.
My god!
Stop!
Stop holding hands!
I'd never get that.
Not even in Eternity Ring would people hold my hand.
I'm so sad.
I wish my hand get held too when I get died by 20 million people.
Where would you go?
Oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Where would you go?
Yeah, they're literally playing.
I hate it.
I hate that they're playing perfectly in quick play.
Quick play is unplayable.
I'm like, why can't my support players hold my hand when I get died by like two.
When I got died by that fucking Hulk yesterday.
Why couldn't my support player hold my hand when I kept getting slapped by the fucking Hulk.
I don't understand how could quick play players like support each other more than Eternity players.
It's just not fair.
It really is not.
Alright, now I'm ready for rank.
I got my hate out.
So like, I should be ready to go.
As long as me watching the W key Hulk walk past my entire team to beat my ass.
It doesn't... I hate to break it to you, but it doesn't change the higher you go.
It's still the same.
Where's Mac?
Oh my god.
I don't think Mac realized.
Do we wait?
Okay.
Wait.
Do we wait for you?
Or...
Or we queue one up?
I don't think... I don't think he got my message earlier.
I don't...
I don't think he got it earlier.
Unity, thank you for the Twitch prom.
Thank you, thank you.
Ghost, thank you for tier one.
Slime, thank you for the donation.
Thank you, thank you.
Now you're a hater?
Are you sure it's not your old hate waking up because you're playing?
It could be that too.
Oh my god, am I the only Trinity player?
Oh my god, I swear to god.
I'm gonna lose so much.
Oh my god.
I thought we were gonna wait for Mac.
I didn't even know we queued up.
Holy shit.
Alright, we'll see how this goes.
I hope this doesn't go terribly wrong.
I'm gonna ban Bruce Banner because fuck that.
After my random about Hulk, I'm gonna ban Bruce Banner.
Oh my god, not my rank roins.
Not my fucking rank roins.
Also, like, whatever happens today, I won't be streaming Marble Rivals tomorrow because my left hand is starting to feel a little cramped.
I've been stretching it but like, I play with my keyboard angled.
Angled a little bit, so it's not really like the best position for like No, it's not my wrist, it's my fingers.
So like, my finger that's on the W and D is like a little cramped, like it's a little crampy so like I'm gonna rest tomorrow.
How do I angle it?
I angle it to like it's like facing, it's like a little to the left.
Alright, Tony Florida.
I'll do Mantis.
Yeah, also let me know, I adjusted the sound a bit so that voice chat is a little louder.
So like, let me know if it's better or or not.
Cause like, I don't know if it's like, if it is better or not.
Yeah, so like, and I've been So like, I think it's, I've been playing a lot of Marble Rivals and I think finally it's caught up.
Remember to always do your stretches if you're planning on playing long sessions of long sessions of Marble Rivals or like FPS games.
But like, surprisingly my right hand is okay.
My right hand is okay.
It's literally like one, two fingers that are feeling sore.
Because I play on a very weird angle when it comes to when it comes to shooter games.
Alright, let's try Alright, let's hope things will be okay.
Let's hope things will be okay.
I'm so confident.
I am so confident.
First game non-Luna.
Let's go.
Alright, damage boost.
Oh my god, that's a lot of low keys.
But that means I can farm.
I can farm some headshots.
Ooh.
Wait, did we...
Oh.
Okay, nice.
We got him.
I usually try to aim the sleep on... Oh my god.
I try to aim the sleep on the ground for like the most efficiency.
You know what?
Let's get rid of this so I can farm some leaves.
There you go.
Nice.
Oh my god, Floga, let's go.
Do your thing, Flo.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Why are you all so low?
What is going on over there?
Okay, okay.
I got a little worried there.
Like, who are you fighting?
Who are you fighting?
Is he still alive?
Oh my god, he was.
He actually...
Guys, guys.
I don't like that he's still alive.
Okay.
And...
He's still alive.
Alright, that's cool.
How is he still alive?
Oh my god.
Yes, I have the ult.
Okay.
Oh my... We're gonna have Starlord ult here.
Oh my god, what the fuck is going on?
Please!
He's literally 1 HP!
I swear to god!
They have strange and Starlord ult.
Guys, please.
We have no defensive ult for that.
Oh my god!
Like, the ult.
I feel like...
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
No.
Goodbye.
This is where I die.
How is he still...
I don't understand!
I don't understand how he's still...
I think we just died on point.
I don't understand how he's still alive.
How did nobody kill him?
Oh my god.
I literally got him one too.
That's like the worst part.
Oh, I'm not gonna peek anymore.
I'm not gonna peek anymore.
I'm gonna farm the leaves right here though.
Oh my god, I missed the dash.
Oh my god.
Please!
We need...
We're down two supports.
We need peel from Panther.
We grew up to two!
Please, we need like one little peel.
That's all.
Oh my god.
Please, I need somebody to come back to help me.
I lived.
Oh my god.
Why did nobody help me?
Why did no one help me when I got pulled?
He's like, no!
Why?
Why did you hit him?
That was lit.
Oh my god.
Push with this.
Starlord won.
Oh my god.
Please.
I didn't mean it.
Black Panther behind me.
Oh my god.
Please, for the love of god, just kill him.
Just actually kill him.
Oh my god.
There's spider on me.
Spider is asleep above.
Siren is one.
Oh my god.
Please.
Holy shit.
He's low.
He's real low.
Oh, I can't peek.
Doctor Strange.
Oh, Panther one.
Panther one.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh.
Let's go.
Yeah, baby.
Oh my god.
That shit was crazy.
Yeah, let's fucking go.
Oh my god.
I have to think.
Oh yeah, can somebody edit the command?
Yeah, the fucking.
Oh my god.
Also, I'm like, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Thank you for enabling my Marble Rivals addiction.
I really appreciate it.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on the YouTubes but today I'm here on Marble Rivals because I want to see if I can get top 500 today.
I need to basically win six games but like.
I don't know about that.
Oh yes, check me out on YouTube.
Enjoy my content.
I forgot to get a cough drop too.
I need to get a cough drop.
I don't know why.
I'm like okay until like I started.
I was totally.
My voice was so okay throughout the day.
It's just like, there's something.
There was just too much hate, I guess.
Alright, damage boosted.
It'll be fine.
Damage boosted again.
It'll be so fine.
Nice!
We're up two.
We should push up.
Wolverine?
Wolf?
One's one.
Is he okay?
Wait, I remember Tony Florida!
He said a slur!
I got him in a game before he died.
Now I remember who he was.
No, I remember.
It was a long time ago.
It was when I was still in Diamond.
But like, he was not a very happy fellow.
Let me tell you that.
He was not a very happy person.
I'm ulting this.
Black Panther to your left.
Strange one.
Strange half.
Alright.
I don't know.
Maybe he got better.
Maybe he's like, more reformed.
Now that he's in GM1.
He's looking for a strange ult.
I am Groot.
They're gonna strange ult after this.
Black Panther to your left.
Black Panther one.
Black Panther's one.
That's literally the only thing I remember.
You're fine.
Oh my god.
He's so healthy.
I gave him all my fucking leaves.
Do something with my leaves.
Jesus Christ.
Black Panther.
I think we should just die on point.
Don't use anything.
Okay.
He used stuff.
Guys.
Oh my god.
I love it when I say don't use anything and then we're just like, you know what?
Fuck it.
Just one would be funny.
Wouldn't it be funny if we just used one though?
But like, just one.
Jesus Christ.
I'm ulting with this.
Let's push.
Strange half.
Oh my god.
Black Panther behind us.
Oh nice.
Nice, we did it.
Oh my god.
Oh, we did it.
Alright.
Yay.
And he didn't go full toxic.
Let's go.
He didn't go.
I'm pretty sure he got better.
It was Diamond.
It was him when he was Diamond.
So like, I'm pretty sure he like...
He like, got better.
I'm pretty sure.
He's GM1 now.
He's a new him, you know?
New Rake.
New him.
Let's check if he's ready.
Yeah, Diamond Diamond is just a different world, you know?
It's a different world.
I was like, why is he...
I was like, oh my god, why do I like...
Oh my god, he queued up another...
I think he didn't see my...
I don't think he saw my message.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Apparently, Zexro was top 100 and now he's GM...
Wait, what?
Wait, is that actually like, a person?
I'm sorry, I mean like...
I'm sorry, that sounded really bad.
I meant more like...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we did raked him!
That's an un-void right there, I'm sorry man.
You're not having a good day.
I'm sorry, but like, I can't have that in my game.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, that's so...
That's...
Oh, yeah.
He's like, oh, he's like one of the best Fortnite players in the world.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
You're not having a good day today.
I'm so sorry, buddy.
It's not you.
It's your elo, right?
It's your elo right now.
It's literally, it's not you.
Oh my god.
You're gonna kick him when he...
No, I'm saying is that I do not want that on my games, guys.
I do not want that in my elo.
I'm sorry, Zexor.
I bet you're an insane Fortnite player.
But like, I'm so sorry.
This is...
We literally deranked you.
I'm so fucking sorry.
Oh my god.
I hope...
Oh, this is...
He started the new year on a lost streak.
Buddy, I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I hope...
I hope you're okay.
I hope you're okay, buddy.
That's rough.
That's so fucking rough.
While he was on my team.
At least you know now, Libra.
At least...
At least you know.
Guys, his luck will turn around.
When you hit a certain loss, you...
It goes all the way around.
Truly, right?
Truly, it can't be that bad.
Truly.
We all have our lost streaks, guys.
We all have our lost streaks.
It's okay.
That's alright.
Oh, he's doom queuing.
I...
This game, like, does something to you.
I would get people asking me...
Like, I would play it off stream.
And they're like, why are you not streaming this?
And I literally tell them, I'm doom queuing.
And then they're like, oh.
It's just like...
They're just like, that's not great news.
But, like...
I'm gonna lie.
Soda, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Doki Braid.
And I stream on YouTube.
But I'm currently streaming my Marvel Rivals rank grind on Twitch.
Because I don't know how long it's gonna fucking take me.
And also, like, I don't know whenever I...
It's always random whenever I do stream.
On Marvel Rivals.
Because it's mostly me just trying to find people.
To play with.
But yes, doom queuing is basically when you're on a lost streak, but you're still going.
So, um...
You just don't stop queuing.
And you're a little tilted, just a little bit tilted, but you don't care.
You're like, in your head, you're like, it'll get better.
It'll get better eventually, right?
At some point, the winner's queue is gonna kick in.
Right, guys?
Right?
I'll stop right back.
I need to go get a cough drop and more water.
I'll be right back.
Oh, Ruckus!
That's the Overwatch Ruckus.
He literally came back from Overwatch and Valorant.
Whoa!
That's crazy.
Seeing Ruckus again.
From Overwatch.
Oh, alright.
I can play Adam.
That's fine.
Bro, you're not even a fucking...
What?!
You're a strange...
Okay.
Bro, this guy didn't even have...
This guy didn't even have, like, a Luna hero portrait.
Or lord, whatever.
I was like, why did you pick Luna?
Why?
I'm banning Bruce Banner.
I don't care what they say.
I'm banning Bruce.
I don't care if you're a fucking Hulk one trick.
I don't want them in my lobby.
I do not want them in my lobby.
He was the one arguing with Bong the other day.
I have...
I play so much.
I play so much Marvel Rivals that I don't know.
I have no idea.
Alright.
Ruckus was an Overwatch League support player.
I'm doing it.
That's basically who Ruckus was.
And I think he moved to Valorant.
Yeah, I'd rather play against a Hella than Hulk because Hulk at least doesn't fucking walk through five people and then slaps me.
Like...
Like, at least I don't have to deal with that.
Like, I would like, at least like Hella at least I get from Hella I get shot from 200 miles away, but like at least that takes skill.
Like, at least at least getting killed by a Hella takes skill.
Getting killed by a Hulk is just my team being fucking blind.
Like...
It's just my team.
Like, I don't know, need to get a fucking eye test or some shit.
I could die of PTSD because I could be like my team's fucking stupid if I die to a Hulk.
Damn.
I'd rather die to Hella.
Ooh, no more.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
He's fine.
He's so fine.
He's so healthy.
Oh.
There's no more up top.
High ground.
I got him.
I'll kill no more.
My son!
There's a Wolverine coming.
Ooh, we can't get you.
Oh no, you got walled off.
That was an insane wall though.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, you're walled off.
Strange.
Jesus Christ.
You're walled off again.
Oh, Grit's low.
Grit's one.
Grit's still low.
Um, you can mantis ult first if you have it.
Alright.
We're taking no team damage.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay.
Alright.
Where's our tank?
I'm just like where's our tank?
Where did he go?
Oh.
He's low.
Yeah, that's nice.
I'm on Grit.
Grit's half.
Grit's one.
Alright, that's fine.
That's... we're fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, he used it.
He used it.
They should have Hella and Wolf ult.
Jesus Christ.
Please, I have to reload my hands.
It's not limited.
It's by what you think.
Alright, there we go.
No, I've been desperate.
I realized I started climbing when I started talking.
And I got desperate.
I can't see you guys.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I'm ulting on point.
Dyna's boosting now.
Dance, everybody!
Dance!
There we go.
We're fine.
There's somebody on top, right?
Unless you're dead.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Punisher.
Oh my god.
They should still have Hella ult.
And their support ults.
Oh my god!
Poki, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god, please, please, please.
Please!
You're taking so much damage!
Oh my god!
Please don't shift.
Oh, that's a huge ult!
I ult first.
We're up one.
I can heal one.
Oh, I'm just gonna push this turret.
I don't have Luna ult yet.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
What?
Who shot me?
Oh, I need to be top off real quick.
Oh god.
Please.
Where's our Mantis?
Oh, thank you!
Oh.
Well.
We lost a lot of people there.
Hahaha!
Oh, that's awkward.
They have Bucky ult here.
Um, I might be able to have ult for it.
Please.
Oh my god!
Okay, I have ult for Bucky.
Okay.
Okay, I'm fucking, I'm swimming a little bit.
That's awkward.
Down one.
Oh, I don't see you, Mantis.
Oh.
Oh, hell is behind us!
Hell is behind!
No!
Mantis!
I couldn't heal you!
It's okay.
We still have three minutes of this.
Surely we won't get full held down here.
At the fucking finish line.
Please.
Please let us heal you.
Please!
You're our only tank!
That's all I ask!
Please!
Okay.
You cannot die.
Oh, I need to get topped off.
Thank you.
Please!
I will start clapping!
You're in the line!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
They're in a line so I can start clapping.
That's like the best thing for me.
Okay, we got another tank.
We finally got another tank!
Oh my god!
I don't know how the fuck they lived through all that.
But good job everybody!
I can't use any of my ults because like...
Okay, okay.
I'm ulting.
Alright, let's go.
Okay!
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
Play near cart if you can.
I might die to hello.
I can't sacrifice myself!
Oh my god!
No!
He got healed!
Oh my god, please!
Please!
Oh my god, you guys are all low and I have to clap.
Do I have to clap?
Hella to the right, hella to the right.
They're gonna have strange ult for this.
Oh, there it is.
Strange one, strange one, strange one!
Magnio, Magnio's on cart.
Yippee!
Oh, please don't touch the cart.
Please, please.
That sleep was crazy!
I like how I was like, goodbye!
Oh, there we go.
It was an incredibly huge eye.
But like, the enemy team didn't push up for some fucking reason.
His team was like, that's pretty cool!
And then they just...
They just let him die, I guess.
They...
I don't know why.
I don't know why the enemy team watched him get like a five man eye.
They're just like, that's really cool!
Watches, yeah.
Awesome job, Strange!
Wish we could do something about it as I watch like, five miles away.
Dude, get him!
Bro, I would not be surprised if the Strange was like, I just got... It's huge!
It's huge!
Where are you guys?
Where is my team?
I would not be surprised if that was the comms on the enemy team.
I went to Doki-Loki.
She's fucking dead.
I mean, to be fair, people are learning how to play Loki now.
Optimally.
So there's so many like, Loki one-tricks now in this ELO.
I don't know how to play Loki in Eternity Ring, because it's actually crazy.
They would go, they use the invisible to like, flank.
Instead of like, using it as an escape, a good Loki player, I've noticed, they would use the Loki invisibility to literally just like, go invisible and then un-viz and like, put a clone in front of them and just get a kill from it.
I've been watching like, pro Loki players do that.
It's actually so scary.
It's so scary and like, and it's like, it's like mind game shit.
Jesus Christ!
How?
I looked away for literally one second.
Oh, you're by yourself.
Oh, tank.
Oh my god.
Oh, you're blocked off.
You're walled off.
Oh my god.
I need to use you for heals.
I...
Yeah, just wait for me.
Oh my god.
I don't know how, I'm gonna orb the Magneto.
I'm gonna orb the Magneto right there.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, Grit's one!
Grit's one!
Jesus.
I'm trying my best.
There's a Moon Knight on the right.
Oh, they double support ulted.
Oh.
How?
Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna Luna ult to stabilize.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Oh, you guys gotta get out of there.
Nice, there's someone behind us.
Moon Knight behind.
Mantis behind us.
Mantis low.
How did we live that?
What the fuck?
I don't know how the fuck we...
That was...
That was three ults.
They used everything but health.
How the fuck?
I'm just surprised we lived that.
Oh my god, stupid ghost.
Oh, I'm clapping just in case because I don't know if they're gonna walk in a straight line.
Mantis is half.
There's a Hela behind us.
Hela's behind us.
I cannot really peek.
Hela's low.
Got Hela.
Hela's half.
Do not stop pushing.
Oh my god.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, live!
They have strange...
Actually, they have Groot, Moon Hul here.
If they combo it, you won't live through Luna.
We're fine,
right?
We're so fine.
Oh, Groot's low, Groot's half, Groot's one.
Oh my god.
Everything is so healthy!
We're so okay!
Oh my god!
Until they do a Groot, Moon Knight combo, then like, things won't be that great to be fair.
Things won't be as healthy anymore, which is a little scary.
Careful of the Groot, Moon Knight combo.
What?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
What?
Okay, okay.
Watch me?
Okay.
Oh, I don't want to group up because of the Moon Knight.
Nice.
I was so confused because, like, he was alive.
I was like, wait.
How was he alive?
Let me reload.
I reloaded my hand.
Oh, nice.
I don't want to be too close because I know they're going to... I'm worried that he's going to Groot ult.
That's like my number one fear.
I think he's waiting for Groot ult right here.
Point, Groot, point.
Please.
Nice.
What is he waiting for?
He's waiting for me to put on a show.
I'm going to let you farm your ult for Mantis.
Yeah, I'm letting you farm it.
I have mine.
There you go.
I'm not even going to heal because I know, like, I want him to have Mantis ult first.
See?
Strategy.
I brought Overwatch strategy over.
He's waiting for the biggest ult of his fucking life.
That's what you do in Overwatch.
If you have ult, you let the other support farm their ults.
What the fuck are they doing?
Are they going to come out?
They're just waiting for the biggest fucking Groot ult of their goddamn life.
It's going to be so huge.
You don't understand.
This Groot ult is going to change everything.
Okay.
You guys.
You guys don't understand.
Dude.
He changed nothing.
Some say he's still waiting for that six man Groot ult.
The ult was so big we couldn't see it.
That's so true.
Oh my god, Silver, thank you for the 20 gifted subs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Next time.
That hurts so much.
Yeah, I know the strange blocked him off the portal, but like that Groot held his fucking ult for too long.
They did the combo one time and then never again.
Like him and the Moon Knight were waiting for the combo because we did not see the Moon Knight or Groot ult for five fights.
It's like...
They didn't see it for five fights.
Also, like, we're Q dodging this because the players were uh...
The players were really special.
Oh, Max saw the message?
He doesn't even fucking reply back!
What the fuck?
That's fucked up.
Has he been winning?
Sorry, I have to reject you.
Alright, let's see.
Oh man, he's...
Oh man, he's in a loop.
He's...
He's... Oh man.
It's okay, we'll turn it around for him.
We'll turn it around.
I'm at my peak at the moment, but things can go...
Uh...
Things can go...
Top shit on my king!
Zexro again?
And you'll have me to deal
Bro, all I said was like...
Bro, I'm sorry, man.
I hope this gets better.
I'm just like...
Okay, look, we all know he had a bad...
He's having a bad day of Marvel Rivals.
Like, I don't want that on my games, man.
I don't want those games.
I...
I'm just like, that's rough, buddy.
That's rough.
She...
I understand the doom queue hours.
I just don't want to be involved.
I just don't want to be part of it.
I need my top 500.
Oh my god.
Alright.
We're just waiting it out.
Because the queues were pretty...
Because like...
Those were some fucking weird ass players.
So I'm just gonna wait out the queue real quick.
Surely one day.
Surely one day we'll be good enough to hit that...
Hit the leaderboards.
I think like...
It's... What is it currently?
It's 138.
So I literally need like...
Three wins.
I don't know.
Things are looking way too good right now.
I don't like it.
I don't like it when they start trying to give me hope.
Every time...
Every time like...
It's... Every time it's like three games, it just...
I don't know.
It feels like things just start going downhill again after that.
Like...
Hope is like...
There's no hope in Marvel Rivals.
There's just...
There's just the grind.
That's really it.
It's just the grind.
You either gain or you lose.
How do you get one above all?
You have to stay on the top 500 leaderboards?
Wait.
Mac might be done soon.
Is he full holding them?
Yeah, he is.
Okay.
So like...
You basically have to stay 24 hours on the leaderboard.
So the moment you get on the leaderboard and you hold top 500 for 24 hours, you get one above all.
That's really it.
The moment you're...
The moment that happens and you're there.
Is he full holding it?
Are they doing it?
Are they actually doing it?
Oh my god.
I'm queuing.
Wait.
Unless... No, there's literally like two guys that's still alive.
Wait, no, they're portaling.
They're portaling.
Blink up.
Blink with Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Blue Hydra.
Blink with Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
No, it's winnable.
Alright, let's see how 3-stack goes.
Every time I 3-stack with two DPS players, it's never been like quite the greatest.
But like, this time it'll be different, right?
This...
Guys, I don't know many...
I literally only know one tank player.
Wait, no!
He's losing!
Okay.
Nevermind.
He didn't full hold.
First point.
I'm not...
Guess we're queuing.
Yes.
I'm more of a strategist.
I think strategist is support, right?
Yeah, I'm a support player.
I'm a support player in Overwatch.
Even though like I can aim, but like, I just enjoy...
I enjoy support.
I don't want to like learn how to be a DPS player.
Because DPS player...
Being a DPS player requires like different positioning.
And like, you gotta know where the fuck health packs are.
And like, my brain... I don't want to handle that.
I don't want to deal with knowing where the health packs are when I can just be a support player and heal myself.
And then being a tank player is just wanting to have a bad time.
Alright.
The goon knight.
I don't know any of these players.
My... Oh my god.
These lobbies are like, not scary, but like I'm scared because like I lose... Oh wait.
No.
I saw... I heard ban back Black Panther and I'm like, I'll be Black Panther.
Really?
Where the fuck is the...
Where the fuck is their Black Panther player?
I have no idea who any of these people are.
Ban Jeff next?
Buddy, I'm... I'm banning... I want... I'm banning Bruce.
I don't want to play against Hulk.
Alright.
Why do we ban Jeff?
Like...
What?
What the fuck?
Bro, I rather deal with a fucking insane... Are you serious?
Okay.
Alright.
This is the worst fucking bans I've ever seen.
That's actually...
These bans are fucking terrible.
Holy shit.
These are actually...
Oh my god.
Alright.
Fucking...
We have Hulk and Iron Man and I guess we're gonna have to play against Hulk and Iron Man.
That's fine.
I'm okay with that.
I'm not.
I'm like... I'm actually...
I'm not okay.
I'm not.
I'm not okay with it, guys.
I don't want... I hate playing against Hulk cause I feel like...
I feel like nobody helps me.
I have to help myself.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's the Rocky Raccoon.
It's the man with no hands.
That's fucking right.
I'm a hater.
Any other... The other supports that have to play would be Rocky Raccoon will agree with me.
Because Rocky Raccoon is one of the few character crew supports that does not peel.
At all.
It's so frustrating.
They literally don't know how to peel.
They don't know how to peel for the other support.
They just fly away.
They fucking... They just fly.
I need heals.
Look at that.
I literally...
I had to just run away.
Alright.
There's a magic on us.
She's frozen.
I swear to god, if after I...
I swear... Please, there's a magic on me.
I swear.
I'm my own peel.
I have to peel for myself.
Oh my god, strangers have...
The support is just sitting on high ground.
Oh.
We can't do...
We can't see where I'm at.
I'm just gonna ult this.
I'm ulting on point.
Oh my god.
Alright.
They're gonna strange ult after my ult.
And then I might die.
Oh, it's alright.
Strange is gonna fuck me up, I guess.
No, he's so low.
I just...
Oh my god, I wish I could just...
Oh, I wish I...
I want...
Literally, the only way I get peeled is if like, I freeze.
I freeze somebody.
You see the Rakurekku run away from me the moment magic shows up?
Yeah, that's why.
That's why I fucking...
I would call it animal control.
Where?
Why?
Bro, solo tank Hulk is so rough.
Not gonna lie.
We got two.
We can push up.
Jesus Christ.
Please!
Oh my god!
Strange is half.
Strange is one.
Please, he's so low.
Hold up, hold up.
I'm gonna try and one-shot Ludo.
Oh my god.
They have it, right?
They have it.
Yeah, they do.
They have ult.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Where's my Iron Man?
Oh, that's me.
Oh my god.
Hulk solo tank is so fucking rough.
It really is.
They're portaling.
Oh my god.
We can't see up there.
I need heals.
I'm gonna get ran down.
It's fine.
There's like, there's two people behind us.
I can ult this.
Are we winning this fight?
Alright, let's fucking go.
Alright, don't!
Hulk, I can't save you there!
Alright!
Oh, we got walled up.
Okay.
I don't like this team comp at all.
We can, but it's just squishy fetching it.
Oh, nevermind.
Magic's one.
Bro, this this comp is ass.
This comp is ass!
Oh, Strange is one.
I hate this comp.
I...
It's such a bad comp.
Like, why are we solo tanking all of them?
Oh my god.
They have Strange ult here.
They haven't used Luna ult at all.
Because I have nobody to trigger Luna ult!
Like...
Like, what do you want me to do?
Nobody is, like, triggering it!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I got a clap.
I got a clap!
Strange is half.
Strange is low.
Oh my god.
Our Ironman's holding off because he wants to do, like, a clip where he fucking kills the Luna!
But it's like, why?!
Why?!
There goes Strange ult after this.
They used Luna ult.
Oh my god!
The hell is wrong?
Did we do anything?!
This Ironman held off for, like, four fights.
I just...
I can't...
This Ironman held off for four fights.
Like, I'm just gonna say, was it...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, like...
I swear, there's a... Strange is half.
Strange is low.
Oh!
I can't see you, Hulk.
Or Ironman.
Guys, get on point!
Stay on point!
Strange is half!
I froze Psylocke behind me.
Oh, we left the point!
What?!
I...
Bro, I need to know why the fuck we...
Why the fuck we saved.
Ironman held off for three fucking fights.
Just use it.
Nothing is triggering...
Nothing is triggering the fight!
Nobody's triggering Luna ult!
I can play Loki if someone Lunas.
Please!
I am giving you Luna!
Guys, it's...
It's okay, I can solo heal.
What?
It's alright.
I hate GM players.
How do you have an ego?
You're a GM.
How do you...
Anybody can hit GM, it's actually...
Oh my god, if you have...
Oh my god.
It's when you're at like...
At like the GM ones to try to get to Eternity, that's where hell truly is.
No, this is absolutely a loss.
Oh wait, I can...
I can heal myself like this.
I'll just clap to heal myself.
That's really it.
I literally can't take damage here.
Oh my god, here we go.
No, this is 100% a loss.
Guys, people just have egos and like, you can't do anything about it.
I need to like, get more claps though.
Literally, this is my only source of healing.
We're up one.
I just have to play extremely safe.
That's really it.
I...
Just nobody wants to play support and that's okay.
I can solo heal.
Just...
Just don't take the health packs.
Like, I...
I need the health packs.
I need to live.
Literally, my only source of heal is this.
So like, do not take the health packs.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna go in with my ult.
Alright.
Alright, it's hell unleashed.
I'm on the cart.
Alright.
No more ult.
No.
Oh, this is where I die.
Alright.
This is where I die.
Yeah, but I need to save my ice ball if I get dived.
That's the thing.
I can't...
I can't like, waste that for heals.
Like...
Like, my ult is so...
My freeze is so important that like, if I wasted on a fucking...
If I wasted on just for the sake of like, healing, it's not great.
Oh my god, how?
Guys!
I don't know if you guys know this, but I'm the solo healer.
I don't know, everybody.
I don't know if it was smart to push up.
Hahaha.
Especially that now that I have like, no second...
See, this is why we ban Bruce Banner.
Hahaha.
You guys caused this yourself.
Like, I don't... Like, you all deserve it.
Like...
You guys literally caused this.
It was so...
It was so winnable.
He's crying too much to play.
It's alright.
He's really angry.
How do you even get a lord on fucking Scarlet Witch?
I think he got angry and started crying.
Hahaha.
Ah, perfectly cool.
You can take it out if you want.
We swapped off.
Oh yeah.
Oh no!
Why am I going rocket?
Hahaha.
Why do they have egos?
I don't understand.
I don't understand why you all have... They have all these egos.
You can only have an ego of your fucking top 100, like, at that point.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Like, every...
Everyone I know is GM.
People, like, would get GM and just make smurfs.
And then they'll get GM and they'll make another smurf.
They can never get past eternity, so they just keep farming GM.
Hahaha.
They should not have an ego.
That sounds sad.
That's literally, like, so many people I know that does that.
It's not even, like... I'm not even being, like, joking about it.
Like, literally, they all do that.
Hahaha.
It's just endless.
That's fine.
Maybe Mac will change all of this.
Mac... Mac doesn't have an ego.
That's fine.
I mean, he does, but, like, he has this fucking Black Panther ego.
But, like, other than that, like, it should be okay, right, guys?
Hahaha.
Like, not even...
Ayy, she got a kill!
Good!
Good for you!
Like, I'm just standing still.
Hahaha.
Ayy, I'm just gonna stand still.
Like, how?
How?
Why are we solo hulking?
I still don't understand.
Oh, hey, look, Berserker Rage.
Oh, no.
Are we gonna play more?
Or... Hahaha.
Oh, my God.
No way.
How did...
We made it through?
There's no...
I won't throw, but still I won't be happy.
Hahaha.
I won't be happy.
I won't be happy, though.
I have to stay on cart, because I actually don't trust people.
Actually, JK.
I'll fucking leave.
Alright.
I'm... Alright.
Bye.
Hahaha.
I won't be happy about this, but I guess we go move on.
The worst part is, like, I have a feeling that we're gonna...
We're... It's...
It's just, you know...
We're gonna get there and then it's, like, we play the extra couple of minutes just to, like, you know...
Oh, there's our Hulk.
Goodbye, Hulk.
Like, why?
Why did you go up?
And then, like, I don't know.
My entire team just falls over.
Like, I don't know.
It's just... It feels like that's gonna happen.
Like, we literally have a baby right now, running around, thinking he's part of the team.
Hahaha.
Goodbye.
Oh, my god.
I... Alright.
If I...
If I knew that sound cue earlier, I... I would've 100%, like, saved his life.
He could've got his ults back, actually.
He actually could've got the ult off.
Yeah.
We went so far.
Hahaha.
Don't worry, you're right.
We have... Oh, man.
I knew it.
We have... Don't worry, guys.
We have Wolverine as the off-tank.
Don't worry.
Woo!
You see... Now you see why I hate Rocket players?
What?
Now you see why I hate Rocket players?
Alright.
Okay.
Guess some people just don't deserve to talk.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, let's...
Okay, what game is he on right now?
Did he just queue up?
How close is he?
How close is your game to ending?
How... How close is...
Okay, how... Sorry.
Close is your game to ending.
Do we wait?
Oh, we spectate him?
Yeah, let's fucking spectate him.
Fuck it.
How do I...
How do I spectate?
Oh, I can't.
Wait, how do I...
I can't spectate?
I thought you can.
We're in second half.
Alright.
Oh, we can.
Oh, when we're on a team, you can't spectate?
Oh, I didn't know that.
Is he losing?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's alright.
It's okay.
It's alright.
Things are...
It's okay.
Oh, the cute quick play.
Alright.
Let's queue...
Let's queue a quick play game.
Cause he's...
He might be a while.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'll just queue a quick play game that we're waiting.
Oh my god, Mac.
Oh my fucking god.
Is he on a low key arc?
Oh my god, I swear to my god.
I cannot have him.
I cannot have him in like...
In a different arc right now.
He is an insane Starlord player.
I cannot have him on like...
Different fucking arcs at the moment.
Wait.
Oh, I guess he doesn't want to play quick play.
Okay, I guess I'll play a quick play game.
Wait, he has one minute left.
Wait, he can actually live.
Wait, there's... Oh, nope.
Nope, they're no more died.
Wait, unless... Oh no, they got a pick.
They're up one.
They're... Oh, they're... Oh, wait.
Wait, it's possible.
Wait, I might not even need to...
Wait, I can spectate, right?
Alright.
There's like a delay apparently if you're spectating.
So like...
It might not...
Be this... It might not like...
He might end and I'm still in this fucking spectating.
Oh, yeah.
There, yes.
Yeah, I literally saw that.
Yeah, there's a huge delay so people can't stream snipe.
Which is smart.
IMO.
Look at him go.
Look at him dance.
You know what I realized?
I realized when Loki is copying Luna...
He's like interslaying.
Like, he's so...
He's such a method actor.
Like, he absorbs into the role of Luna.
Yeah.
Cause like, that Luna ult is literally Loki.
Being like...
Being fabulous.
He's like so hard.
Wait, I think they might win.
I think they're gonna win this.
Oh, please win this.
Please so I can queue up my next game.
Please.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, I should've asked really nicely.
I was like, can I have a Loki?
Oh my god.
Oh, why did I ask really nicely in voice chat and be like...
Hey guys.
Can I have a Loki?
I mean my team.
Loki.
I love his hair.
Hey everybody.
I really think if we have a Loki, we can win, guys.
They're not.
My Sochi would never.
My Sochi guys wanna win.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Oh, they lost the point.
God fucking dammit.
Sorry, spoiler ahead.
They lost the point, guys.
No, instead like, my teammates got super racist instead.
Which was...
Which was not a fun time.
Instead of that, I had to deal with my teammates not being very happy.
Who's this?
Our third.
That's stuck in the fucking game.
And like, I don't know if they're gonna win or lose.
I mean, they have 45 seconds left.
My Oshi not wanting to win.
Who are... No, I know, right?
Next time, guys.
Next time.
To be fair, it's a 50-50.
Cause then, they'll just be like quiet.
So like, you know.
I can't be 100% sure that they'll actually swap to Loki.
Because then there's the possibility where they're like, quiet.
And then I'll be like, okay.
Like...
So like, you know.
It's not guaranteed.
Are they winning?
No, they're...
I can't tell if they're winning or losing.
Oh, that's smart.
Wow, Mac, that's actually so fucking smart.
They lost.
That was smart, though.
They C9'd.
That was very smart.
I appreciate how smart that was.
Alright.
I hope to God he doesn't forget again.
I hope to God.
It's alright.
Things will be okay.
I swear to God.
If he queues one more game, I swear to fucking God.
Alright.
And then...
Um, wait.
What happened to our third?
Was it...
Yeah, that's it.
It'll be funny if...
If like...
I just invited the wrong Drake.
Alright, he...
Where did the third go?
Oh!
Okay, never mind.
Alright, well...
I hope they like...
Request to join.
I hope they...
The forever incomplete party.
How did we lose one over the other?
How did that happen?
I thought we were all ready.
I thought we were gaming.
Where did they all go?
Waiting for...
The third.
Oh my God.
They are the same person.
It's just Mac on his other monitor.
I can only have one.
I can never have three.
I can never have...
I can only duo.
I can never trio.
Apparently.
It's the three stack in the room with us.
Right now.
My games have been...
That's great to hear!
Please!
Why would you say that?
Why would you?
Oh my God.
For those who don't see.
I'm so mentally...
Strong right now.
Please.
I want...
We are not...
Duo queuing.
Oh my God.
I recruited a...
Duo queuer.
Oh no.
No.
This can't happen right now.
Oh my God.
It's going to turn around.
I swear to God.
It's going to turn around right here.
Right now.
I believe.
Surely he's not going to...
Doom cube his way.
Yeah.
Please.
We were so close.
We were doing so well.
Oh my God.
My third pick is going to take...
20 minutes?
We were all looking at the same stream.
I get randoms.
Didn't have to fight.
Surefour, Sinatraa, and Rockus.
Oh man, that's actually rough.
That's a rough queue.
Wait, are they all still on?
Hey, Surefour got off.
You should be fine now.
Surefour got off.
Why did you add Drake as a friend?
Drake's a solo act.
They don't care.
They don't want Drake.
Drake doesn't care.
He's too busy.
He's too busy making...
Diss tracks right now.
We just need the trio buff.
Do we just...
I guess we just queue as a duo.
Alright.
Alright, I will wait...
I will wait two more minutes...
And if Drake fucking disappears...
And I'll have to write his next diss track.
Sorry, not second.
He has so many diss tracks.
If he's not here...
In two more minutes...
He's too busy.
We're queuing up.
And then maybe losing.
Because Mac's doing queuing.
So I'm a little scared.
Oh, sorry.
Kendrick.
I mean, yeah.
Drake loves himself too much.
Drake loves himself too much to be a hater.
Sorry, Kendrick's going to be writing his next diss track.
So he's not here, I think.
I think he actually disappeared.
I think he actually...
He actually just fucking vanished.
Like...
Alright, I queue at 25.
If they don't...
If they don't come back...
They're not at Gus.
The Doom queuing is strong.
We're going to go straight into Doom queuing.
Now...
We lost our third.
It ends in six days.
Oh my god, it ends in six days.
We actually have a timer now.
We can see when it ends.
Oh my god, I hope I can make it.
I hope I can make it.
Mac and Matt...
Thank you for the Twitch Prime and Tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Alright, it's almost 25.
It's almost 25.
I literally was like...
I've been like adding.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
You know MaxQ wasn't going to take fucking 20 minutes to finish.
He's gone.
He actually...
He's never coming back.
I hate that.
Alright.
I guess we go in.
Alright, I'm a little scared now.
I'm a little scared now.
I was like, yeah, three stack.
I feel so comfortable.
At least I have two players to rely on.
I guess it's just...
I don't know now.
I believe in him.
But then he told...
I was going to believe in him.
But then...
But then he's like...
My games have been held the past three hours.
Went from 240 to 70.
And then like...
Then I sort of stopped believing.
I don't know.
It's sort of hard to...
It's sort of hard to believe.
My optimism gone.
It's all gone.
The low key arc.
The believe only can...
The believe can only work...
Work at a certain amount.
I was a little optimistic.
I was optimistic.
Then everything went downhill.
Because I lost the third.
Kendrick Lamar disappeared on us.
And then...
Mac is not having a great rank session right now.
So like...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Let me give you guys a natural prop review.
Where is he?
Wait.
Actually.
Where is he?
There you go.
There we go.
That's a real view right there.
Woah.
The other ladies wish they were like Venom.
Venom.
Thank God.
Not my birthday so wild.
Okay.
Woah.
Mama.
Oh my God.
They wish they were...
They were...
As thick as Venom.
I missed third person.
Alright.
I have no idea who like...
Majority of these people are in my lobby.
I forgot to get rid of East Coast.
I forgot.
No.
I'm not used to being the party leader.
For those who don't know, people like...
Get rid of East Coast servers when they play.
Because like...
East Coast is like...
The Elo terrorizers.
Dude, I don't want to have a hell of my game bro.
The only games I've lost these...
I mean, I don't know.
The only games I've lost today is against...
Oh, there he is.
Alright.
Hawkeye.
Goodbye Hawkeye.
Bro, if I have to play against Hawkeye, I'm gonna...
Hawkeye.
I've had this.
I've had to play against Hawkeye.
In five out of seven games.
Do they have a Hawkeye main?
I don't know.
But the Hawkeye always dropped fucking 30 kills or more.
In like two deaths.
It was horrible.
Why did you not tell me Kendrick Lamar went and took a shower?
I'm sorry.
Drake's big hater.
Apparently they like typed it in chat.
It was like...
Bro, I typed it in chat.
I was like, I'm gonna go take a shower.
You guys didn't say anything.
I was like, where are you?
Yeah, he did.
Oh my god.
You guys should have spammed that.
They did it.
Who's we?
I didn't see it.
So I don't think it existed.
Someone did though.
Yeah, but it had to be a wall.
He's not gone.
He's out of shit.
I thought he disappeared.
Guys, the only way I can read it is if it's like...
If it's like the same thing.
Like ten times in a row.
See, I didn't see it.
There you go.
You did not spam it.
I fucking know you guys didn't.
I can't read either.
No, I can't.
I can't fucking read.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's go, I believe.
I push cart and I'm gonna believe so hard.
And like...
Things will be okay.
Woah!
Oh my god.
I got no reg on that though.
You're so healthy!
I'm gonna put it on...
Our tanks now.
I'm gonna be the only one that gets rid of the more shit.
Okay, now I can put it on...
I'm gonna put it on Starlord.
Because we have three supports.
So like...
Please.
Why is he just chilling up there for free?
Oh my god, he's so healthy.
He's so healthy.
You can Mass Assault first.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
I froze Starlord, I froze Starlord.
Okay.
Oh my god, it doesn't matter.
Can we make any progress?
Let's find out.
Oh!
You're all so alive.
For somehow.
Somehow.
Can we kill...
Oh my god, please.
Wait, there's a Starlord behind me.
Starlord behind us.
Starlord half.
I have Starlord behind us.
Oh my god, please!
How is he still alive?!
Starlord 1 HP on the top.
Ah, somebody shoot him!
I shot him!
Oh my god!
My dad keeps shooting him!
Oh, that's unlucky.
Unlucky.
Oh, that's so unlucky.
That is...
I peeled so much.
Oh my god, and then there's a Wolverine?!
Where did he come from?!
Guys...
I'm...
I'm not feeling hopeful anymore.
I'm above.
Alright.
Who's running?
Just play around it on me.
Alright.
My ult ending here.
Oh my god, why did you push up?!
Wolverine's low.
What?!
Wait!
Oh my god!
Why did you push up?!
We can combine Mantis ult.
Mantis, you ready?
I need you to help me though.
We're attaching, Siren.
Alright.
Wolverine's behind us.
This is weird.
No, I had...
Oh my god.
I think...
Guys, does this look like...
a winning queue?
This is...
Hey, wait, there's a portal!
Oh my god, Wolverine's low!
That was my bad shit, waking up Wolverine.
Guys, I got into max doom queues.
It is what it is.
It's fine.
Surely we can turn around max doom queues.
I think we can.
I think it's possible.
Their queues...
Their que...
The queues can't be doomed forever.
I...
It can't be doomed forever.
There's like...
At one point, it turns around, guys.
At one point.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be GM one, guys.
Oh my god.
I'm so excited.
That makes it easier, right?
That's how it goes.
Games get easier when you're in GM one.
Right?
Right, guys?
Is that what we're...
Okay, we still have...
We still have a tank.
Surely I won't drop all the way to GM two like that guy.
That poor guy.
That really poor guy.
My ego has already been really small.
I say as I fucking scream at a Rocket Raccoon player yesterday.
It's as small as...
It's smaller than a DPS player.
Like, no matter what.
Oh, you are so healthy though.
You're so healthy.
I clapped.
What?
Oh.
Bro, he got bubbled?
Oh my god.
Guys, I can't clap again.
I can't clap again.
I'm sorry.
I tried so hard to clap.
I'm clapping as fast as I can.
Clapping is so hard.
It hurts.
Oh my god.
Clap, clap, clap.
Clap, clap.
I can feel it.
I can fucking feel it.
I feel the kidnapping.
Oh my god.
Oh,
you know who's...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know how they all died.
Ow.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We got Kendrick Lamar back.
Oh my god.
Fucking get rid of... I'm sorry.
I'm deleting the east coast.
I...
Like I said.
It's okay.
I'm deleting the east coast.
Don't worry.
Oh, that hurts.
That actually hurts.
I'm sorry, east coast.
But your lobbies are known as like...
The terrorizing lobbies.
As they are.
Your lobbies are actual.
I'm sorry.
I gotta remove you.
Alright.
Honestly.
I don't even know who.
They...
Everybody was just terrible.
I don't know.
Who was the worst one?
They were all pretty fucking...
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
They were all pretty special.
The rocket raccoon.
To be fair, he was on Mantis.
To be fair.
Like...
I don't know.
He was on support too.
Like...
Was the rocket that bad?
He was on Mantis.
To be fair.
Avoid the rocket on principle.
I'm sorry.
The chat has voted.
I didn't want to avoid you.
But chat was just like...
Just avoid him.
I don't like being party leader.
It's too much pressure.
Why would I give somebody party leader?
Oh, I'll do it later.
Chat demands a sacrifice.
It's not...
It wasn't my decision.
The chat voted for you to...
For you to get avoided.
Just so they know.
I didn't want to do it.
Alright?
It wasn't...
It wasn't my choice.
Okay.
There we go.
The true...
Eye candy here.
This is what we want.
Just give the people what they want.
I heard the new ice skin...
Is like...
Like a bigger bulge.
Oh, pervert?
Oh yeah.
Just because I picked Venom.
If I had Luna Snow.
Or Cloak and Dagger.
Or Squirrel Girl.
Nope.
But when I choose Venom.
I get judged.
Just because I picked Venom.
I'm getting judged.
All cake is good cake.
Society.
Venom is an...
An...
Fucking half the...
Half the fucking roster...
Aren't even real humans.
They're not even fucking humans.
They're metahumans.
And they don't deserve...
And metahumans...
Aren't...
Okay.
Sorry.
Mutants, metahumans.
They're like the fucking same thing.
They all don't...
Don't go there.
It's literally the same thing.
Just different names.
Same prejudice.
The Tarvis didn't leave the bot.
She hit my head.
That D.Va was right.
Did you not watch X-Men?
Oh my god.
Oh, this is a weird last fucking lobby.
We removed East Coast.
We cut off the East Coast.
Mutants aren't even real!
Why are we defending mutants?
They're not even real!
Doki's gotta get cancelled.
Cancelled.
Cause they're friends.
They're not even real!
Woah!
They're not real people now!
The mutant erasers shake my head!
I'm batting mantles cause we have Cloak and Dagger players.
So fuck that.
Nookie claims they're not real humans.
I knew they were gonna ban Hela so I was just like, I'm just gonna ban this guy.
Are you batting her?
Cause she's a She's a fucking alien!
That's different.
And we all appreciate aliens here.
We all appreciate aliens.
That's why I'm a Venom enjoyer.
I'm about to get cancelled on xmen.com.
I should've banned Neknito.
Should've just banned all the xmen characters.
Doki's playing a mutant she can't possibly.
She can't possibly.
No, Luna Snow is different.
She's my exception.
She's a K-pop star.
She's a celebrity.
She's different.
Her music's good, so it's different.
She's not like the other mutants.
Yeah, she got her powers from a snow machine.
It's different.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, cute.
Name one Luna Snow song.
Yeah, you test me on that.
Bit by a radioactive snowflake.
Help our Starlord.
I got her tank.
I froze, I froze.
There's a Panther, any help?
That was a sick freeze.
You see, this is why Luna's my exception.
I need to be topped off here.
That's fucking right.
Now you know why.
That's fine.
Two, no more, two left.
Yeah, they're above me.
I'm countering, girl.
There's a strange pushing me.
Oh, no!
They all pushed me!
I couldn't help!
Uh...
You're down one.
Oh, wait, nevermind.
You're down two.
If you guys can regroup, I can ult in.
Mac, live, live, live.
I'm ulting in.
Oh, my god.
Alright.
I have to back out in two seconds.
Backing out now.
They have a strange ult, they have a strange ult.
I froze strange, but I'm ulted too.
Oh, my god!
That was such a good freeze!
That was actually a great freeze, too.
Poor me and the guy.
God damn it, if I can kill Vanita.
Damn ult.
Oh...
Bro, I can't...
Oh, my god.
Oh, I can't do anything!
No!
I'm sorry!
Oh,
my god.
Oh, my god.
Poor me and the guy.
What?
Oh, that's ours?
I didn't realize that was our ult.
I thought...
There's a match behind us.
We're up two.
We should push up.
I'm on cloak as well.
Respawns are coming back in front of us.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting this.
Oh, the Sylas coming back now.
I'm backing up now.
Oh, they...
Yeah.
That was not...
I saw the Magneto, I was like, you're not living that.
You're not...
Bro...
Poor me and the guy.
Why does this always happens to me?
Every time I...
Every time I hate.
Guys, just don't be a hater.
I just gotta stop being a hater, I guess.
Guys, I'm reformed.
I love mutants.
I love all mutant kind.
In fact, I'm gonna make a donation now to Professor Xavier's School of Mutants because I've learned about I believe in all mutant kind and my donation to Professor Xavier's Mutant School shall show how much I believe in them.
Professor X's award cramping up.
Psylocke has ult.
Guys, pick one!
Do we fight for mutants or not?
Fake apology because of the backlash.
That's not true.
I believe in all mutants.
Believe mutants.
Oh my god.
Please live.
Oh, except for you.
Fuck you, I guess.
Bring out the ukulele.
Oh no.
Oh, what do I do there?
I fucking apologized!
What more do you want?
We gotta touch.
Please, I had to touch myself.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Please.
Magneto's low.
Stay on point, please.
It's point 50.
Oh my god, okay.
There we go.
It's personal.
I believe in their existence.
What more do they want from me?
I don't have my ult, so if you guys can let me, help me build ult.
I'm 10% from ult.
I'm 2%.
Oh.
Right on point if you have to.
I can ult those enemies.
They're gonna Psylocke ult right after.
Oh, they have Psylocke ult and Strange ult.
No more ult.
Magneto's one.
Oh, never mind.
Stay on point if you can.
Oh, nice!
Let's go!
There we go.
Alright.
We win this and I was justified.
I was right.
Wait, what?
She wasn't sorry.
I'm not dumping.
If Magneto wins this, then he was right.
If I win this, then I was right.
Two-faced apology.
Right here.
Mag on Starlord.
Yeah, Mag's really good at Starlord.
Yeah, the whiplash is crazy.
Namor is not immune and he's a fucking, he's an Atlantean.
That's different.
That's different and he's hot too.
Bro, I cannot wait for it.
Apparently, Namor and Mrs. Fantastic has like a history behind each other so I can't wait.
I can't wait to see.
I wanna know if they actually know the history behind Namor and Mrs. Fantastic.
He's a, no!
He's more Atlantean.
Wait, does Mrs. Fantastic know?
I don't know, but I'm pulling up a chair for him.
He can be two things.
Yes, oh yeah, yeah.
He has, Namor and Mrs. Fantastic has a thing going on.
I don't know how Mr. Fantastic's gonna feel, but I mean like look at Mr. Fantastic and then look at Namor.
Like, can you really blame her?
Can you?
Oh, we're even.
There's a...
Oh my!
Okay, but like, but like in comparison with the two.
Okay, but also look at Mrs. Fantastic.
You really
blame...
We're even.
We're up one, we're up one.
Oh my god.
I froze somebody, I think.
Feels bad for him.
We're down two, we're down two.
There's no point in ulting this.
Alright, we have two DPS coming over now.
Oh!
Okay, I'll ult in, I'll ult in.
I'm ulting.
You guys gotta win here.
They have no luna.
That's a huge ult, that's a huge ult!
Oh, magic.
Goodbye, I might die!
Okay.
There's so many I have to kill.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, strange has ult, strange has ult and they have support ults here.
Oh, nice.
Alright, there we go!
Get her, Mania, stop!
What did I do to deserve this?
I say it as I...
I say this about Mutant.
I'm just saying what everybody's saying out loud.
Wait, oh no.
Maybe I did deserve to lose this.
What the fuck?
What happened to my...
No way!
This is...
Oh my god.
No fucking way.
This is...
Oh my god, this is crazy.
Oh, I'm solo healing, I know there's a point to see.
This is crazy.
This is actually crazy.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god, who fucking...
Who told them?
Who told them who I was?
This is embarrassing.
We can't even be even!
Please come back.
Please.
Come back!
Please!
Please come back!
Please clock!
How did they do that?
Please come back, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'll donate to the Mutant Cause after.
Please.
Where did they go?
Guys, I don't think I can do this.
I don't think so.
We have a guy that swapped Black Panther.
Because like, I don't...
I think he gave up.
That's so unlucky.
This was so winnable.
If we had two healies.
Why on my team?
Why couldn't this Cloak and Dagger be on the enemy team so I could have farm?
Oh my god.
Is Cloak and Dagger immune?
Is she immune?
Is my hate justified?
Of course.
She's not.
Oh my god.
Not even a Mutant?
I'm gonna avoid this person.
I'm gonna avoid them.
I'm gonna I'm gonna avoid this Persecute again.
He's fucking...
So much hate.
Alright.
You guys are somehow alive.
What happened?
Did your mom unplug your fucking internet?
What the fuck happened to you?
Bro!
Like, did your mom said it's 1am?
I can't unplug this internet.
Oh, and he's back!
And this fucker's back!
At least the car is right there.
How did you dodge it?
It took 3 minutes.
I'm here!
Lock in!
It took...
Magneto's on Kite!
Please just kill that Magneto.
I got us this time.
Oh my god.
Magneto's 1!
This truly is hell.
I think I'm in hell.
I need someone to stay on Kite so I can heal in the back.
Please.
Play on Kite.
Play on Kite if you can.
Okay, play on Kite!
Why does nobody understand the word KITE?!
He walked out of
the guy that DCs walks out of my all.
Run away.
It's the streamer family.
Oh my god.
Not anymore.
Justice at last.
Okay.
Alright.
I can't.
I can't deal with this guy.
How do you 20?
There's no way.
Wait a minute.
How do you 20?
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Guys, no.
Don't say that.
Don't fucking say that.
Guys.
No.
He has 21k healing.
That's why I'm like, how do you have that?
What happened?
Magneto was not right.
Guys.
He is a criminal.
Magneto is literally a criminal.
Guys.
But Jiro, thank you for them.
Thank you for the raid.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Magneto is just...
I was just cloaking dagger.
It's alright.
I avoided you.
I'm sorry but I can't have these tears in my team.
But thank you for them.
Thank you for the raid.
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube but like, I'm on Twitch right now because I guess I want to cry my rivals and I hate myself at the moment because we are... We're essentially at Doom queuing territory.
We've hit it.
Exactly.
This is a serious game and there's no DCing allowed in my team.
Damn.
That's fine.
We can have one tank.
That's alright.
Yeah, I took East Coast out.
That was the first thing I did.
Alright.
That's fine.
What?
Okay, that's fine.
I don't like dual streaming.
No, I'm not a fan of it.
I don't like splitting.
I don't like splitting the chat because I have to read two different chats and I'm already too distracted with one chat.
Like...
Yeah, it's...
I'm already too distracted with one.
Alright, we take that three tanks.
You're right.
We have our little off tank right here.
This is such a dive heavy team.
It's going to be interesting.
I can't believe...
I can't believe we got the PC.
Like, how did it take three minutes to reconnect?
What's wrong?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
I'm just waiting to see if we can adopt another tank player.
Honestly.
That's like...
I'm a little worried because I hear...
Oh, nevermind.
It focused on me.
Nevermind.
The focus was on...
Like, I got fucking...
I saw the Wolverine came back and I was like, whoa.
What the fuck?
Everyone's dead.
Here I go.
What?
I don't know.
What do you mean?
I got blew up.
Oh my god.
That's what happened to me right there.
What the fuck?
Use my ability.
What?
What do you mean?
That guy talks shit.
Hasn't happened to him.
Actually.
He talks shit and he got hit by it too.
Fuck off.
What happened to me?
I don't know.
You saw what happened?
Use your fucking abilities, I guess.
Well, time just won.
I'm teaming with that Mantis.
Actually, crazy thing to say to me.
Use your ability.
I don't play it.
I don't play it, play around me.
We're gonna have Strangel here.
Still can't.
Why is...
Guys, I have three people pushing me.
Oh my god.
There's a Magneto and Starlord on our Mantis.
Support needs help.
Alright.
Actual fucking karma for that guy that said use your fucking abilities.
And then it happened to him again.
I'm just like, bro, you can't say that.
I'm literally like, what the fuck do you want me to do at that point?
Oh!
Oh, Magneto's half.
Magneto's low, Magneto's low.
Oh, it's Black Panther on me, Black Panther!
Oh!
Where did he go?
Magneto, I hear that and I fucking run.
And then...
Still, I'm still fucking, I'm mad.
You're using my C!
Oh shit, but you're right, I have a C.
You're right, no, this is my bad.
I didn't use my C.
I don't play with Iron Fist a lot, I forgot about my C.
I'm playing on point.
Oh my god.
Alright, C!
It doesn't matter.
Oh my god.
Alright, that was the one time he was right.
I forgot about the C.
The C didn't work though.
The C didn't work.
Guys, this guy's a Lord Panther.
Max not a Lord Panther.
What does he even do?
It like, makes it so that people don't dive as heavily.
If I get dived, I can see and I'll heal myself and push them away.
Yeah, it pushed people back.
I never had to use it until now.
That fight.
Or the last fight there.
The last fight where I got died by Black Panther.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I think I'm gonna be GM-1 after this.
Yeah, because we don't...
Normally, you don't...
Guys, it's okay.
We can climb back up.
It's okay.
I believe.
I believe in the climb back.
And the C is gone now.
I got experience C for like one time.
Wait, why are you on Black Panther, Max?
Also, why...
Why are we on Venom?
I don't know if we need Venom here.
What?
How does that not shield me?
Oh, Magno won.
Magno's won.
Alright.
Yeah, that's why I said I don't think we need...
Uh...
I don't think we needed, uh...
Venom.
Just cause like...
The only die we have is...
I mean, to be fair, we do have Wolverine and Black Panther.
Black Panther's won!
Oh my god.
No!
Guys, I'm trapped!
Is it still winnable?
Oh, I'm fighting on point.
That's fine.
Okay, I guess I'll be the only one on point.
That's okay.
We're just gonna stall on point.
That's fine.
They wasted Star Lord ult.
We got it.
50%?
That's late.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
Oh my god!
Wait, Mag, you go Star Lord?
Oh, okay.
What?!
I don't mean like that.
I mean like, people are gonna bitch.
Wait, Mag!
Come on!
Mag!
I can't have you!
Dude!
Mag!
Guys.
Guys, I can't.
Oh my god!
I can't have you explode!
Please, it's so winnable, Mag!
We can't have you fucking explode right now!
Mag is like slowing down.
Oh my god.
We're up three.
Mag, I can't have you fucking mental boom on me.
Mag, I can't.
Mag, I can't have you mental boom.
Please!
Oh my god.
This is very unfortunate.
What an unfortunate time we're in.
Help her over, help her over if you can.
I'm out, I'm out.
Okay.
I have to ult this.
Stay on me, stay on me, stay on me.
Just stay on me.
Black panther low.
I have a starlord on me.
Starlord low.
He has, he has, he has ult too.
Alright.
I can't have him blowing up.
Music makes people happy.
Heroes make them safe.
Maybe I can do both.
Oh my god.
Drake was like, Drake was like, why don't I have snowflake?
And I was like, cause Mag's on panther.
And he's like, I don't care.
I-
Let him suffer.
Okay.
Alright, snowflakes on Drake.
Oh my god.
He's like, I can carry.
Give me the snowflake.
Oh my god.
So warm in the stack.
My stack is blowing up.
My stack is...
Everybody.
There's a black panther on support.
It's okay, I killed that one.
There's a black panther.
It's okay, I killed their tank also.
Maybe it's not okay.
It's not okay that black panther killed us.
Oh man, I wanna do what black panther's doing.
It's okay.
I don't think Mace wants to play.
Black panther.
Oh no.
My favorite part where they're like, it's okay.
I have a starlord on me.
I might die.
It's not winnable.
The girls are fighting.
I can't do anything.
Does everyone just play for fun when they hit DM1?
What's up with that?
Bro, I'm like King Eternity, what do you mean?
I was Eternity.
After Eternity, Mace was like, peace.
I did my job.
Eternity.
Alright, I'm just gonna stay here.
I'm just gonna stay here.
My god.
Why do they get to have fun?
Why do the enemy team get to have...
Guys, I think Max's mental is actually...
I don't know what we can do to save his mental.
I actually don't know what to do.
My stack's fucking fighting too.
It's over.
Nice try, Horde!
Oh my god!
Zac is crashing out now.
Oh.
That was... It was nice being Eternity for like half a day.
Bye.
Oh hey, I'm SPP though.
I'm SPP.
Oh shit, they've been muted.
Guys, see?
The reporting system works.
The reporting system works, guys.
I don't know.
What should we do, guys?
What do we do?
Do we keep going?
I feel like...
I feel like he's crashed out.
I don't know.
Break up the stack?
Do we break up the stack?
Eternity or nothing?
Do we try to get...
I'm sorry, boys.
I'm breaking up the stack.
We gotta break up.
I'm sorry, everybody.
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Back to...
Stack is angry at each other.
Yeah, my stack is angry at each other.
They were not happy.
Okay, let's see.
I need to avoid...
Actually...
Oh no.
I don't think I need to avoid anybody, honestly.
It was just...
Oh my god, that actually hurts.
Oh my god, I was doing so well, too.
Things were going so well.
No.
They both wanted Snowflake.
Alright.
Okay.
Kendrick Lamar was like, give me one more chance.
But if we lose the next game...
If we lose the next game, it's solo time.
They were like, just give me the Snowflake.
Just, okay.
Alright.
Alright, we'll see.
They were like, give me the Snowflake, and it'll be fine.
We'll see how it goes.
Maybe it will be fine, who knows.
Who knows.
East Coast is...
Did you remove...
East Coast?
We just gotta...
We just gotta like, find a tank player and adopt them.
Okay, if we get a really good tank player on our team, I'm gonna be like, join.
If we find a...
Okay guys, we're gonna fucking adopt a tank player.
We could find a tank player, I believe.
I believe.
No, the issue with this always...
I think the issue is always like, if you trio stack with two DPS players, there's always gonna be inter-fighting with the DPS players.
I've noticed.
I need to find a tank player to adopt.
Tank is so important.
It's like, literally the game changer.
If we can just like...
Are we Q-dodging?
What are we doing?
Are we...
Q-dodging?
Oh, we are.
No, Max Doom infected me.
His like, fucked up lobbies infected my fucked up lobbies.
So things got...
Things got intense.
Things got...
Mays hit rank one last night?
No, he didn't.
He lost it.
I don't know if he's trying to get it back.
He's rank number two now.
Don't worry.
We'll be able to adopt a tank.
It's possible.
A miracle's gonna happen at four in the morning.
I believe it.
I believe we will have a miracle at four in the morning.
There's always hope.
Oh my god, now we're in the GM one lobbies.
Oh my god, I'm back in the slums.
Hello everybody.
I'm back in the...
I once saw what it was like up there.
I'm back in the slums.
I saw what it was like back up there.
It was beautiful.
Those eternity games felt like heaven.
It was so beautiful and then I got kicked out.
I got kicked out of heaven and now I'm here.
Now I'm here.
Back into the clown lobbies.
We don't have a tank player?
Better?
A better Hawkeye?
I only play spider.
Fucking hell.
It's okay.
Wait, who said that?
Well, you'll get Hawke or we do.
We got...
Oh, fuck it.
Let's just ban Bounty.
Fuck it.
Somebody on my team can play Helga.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
We literally just need one tank player.
Nice.
We have our one tank player.
That's...
That's fine.
Everything will be okay.
We might be back in the slums, but like surely we won't be there forever.
Right, guys?
Surely.
Alright, we don't end until we get eternity... Okay, I'm changing my title again.
Not ending until eternity.
Back at it again.
Instead of top 500.
Maybe top 500.
It's not.
It's like deja vu.
Not again.
Not ending until eternity again.
We're back, guys.
Oh my God, it's just like last time.
Guys.
Alright.
Now he can't complain about the snowflakes.
And we're like...
I don't know.
I think this was on stream.
We're like...
They're like, I need a snowflake.
The tank.
And they're like...
Who cares?
DPS players, am I right?
Wait, now we have two tank players?
Oh my God, I've never seen two tank players in my...
In all these streams we've been playing.
This is rare.
Alright.
We need to adopt a tank, though.
Avoid Spider-Man?
I mean, Spider-Man and this heal though.
They're like...
I mean, he's doing really well.
Not gonna lie.
Oh,
I need heals.
Oh my God.
Goodbye, Spider-Man.
Goodbye.
They're walled up again.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Oh!
Shit.
Oh, group behind us!
Group behind us!
Mantis ult first, if you want.
There's more behind us.
Where's our...
Mantis ult?
Where's our Mantis ult?
Where was it?
Wait, the low-key one-trick is on Magneto?
What happened?
I can't see you.
Strange.
We gotta pick.
We're up one.
Magneto half.
We're up two.
Left side no more.
That's a huge ult.
They have Groot ult.
There it is.
There's the Groot ult.
I'm on one.
That's fine.
That's so fine.
Not a one-trick anymore.
That's when you know the Q's been very doomed.
That's...
Jeff is low.
No!
Can you reload?
I'm stuck on a tree.
I might be dead.
I have 5 HP.
I'm stuck on a tree.
A tree.
Oh yeah, what happened?
I'm Spiderman only.
What happened?
Oh my god.
What a character.
There's...
There's walled off tanks.
There's someone behind us.
I don't have ult for Groot ult.
Or Psylocke ult.
I'm 85 though.
You can farm for me.
Yeah, you might get it faster.
Yeah, he has to take damage so I can...
I'm 90.
I got it.
Oh, please!
It's kind of fat.
I'm Jeffed.
I got Jeffed.
Nice.
I got it.
Walled tank.
Alright,
next time we'll do Mantis ult first.
Yeah, my bad.
I thought you used it already.
I'm not gonna die.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Everything is fine!
Oh, get Groot.
Get Groot.
Yeah, nice.
Everything is so gay!
I'm dancing!
Yippee!
You're so healthy!
Oh, he's not.
He's a bitch.
He's not healthy.
I froze Magneto.
I'm ulting this.
Play him out.
I like Mantis.
Magneto will have...
That's a huge crit ult.
Huge crit ult.
Oh, good fight.
Get Groot.
There's a Magneto on supports.
Magneto low.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm on Groot.
Oh, there is an Amour behind us.
Amour is still behind.
Oh, no.
Hey, Luna ulted though.
We have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
We can contest with my ult.
Hold on, I'm coming back.
There's still a chance to stop them.
I don't know what happened there.
But like, I got...
It's a little scary.
Nice, we're even.
Psylocke is half.
He has ult.
I got Psylocke.
It's just Groot.
Okay, it's Groot.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
Groot won, Groot won.
Luna?
Luna is frozen.
Nice, nice.
There's too much yellow and it's 4 AM.
There's too much yellow.
Okay.
You guys see what he said?
Yeah.
Yeah, why am I...
Guys, it's 4 AM.
Why are you yelling?
Why am I yelling?
Guys, it's not even 4, it's 1.30!
It's 1.30.
The night is still young.
What is an EZ doing in my queues?
What is he doing in my queues?
What is EZ doing?
I thought I cut you out.
It's fine.
The day is young, exactly.
We're back to the...
Not stopping until eternity.
It's like we never left.
It's like a little...
A little bit of...
Guys, are you okay if I just stream Marvel Rivals until I get top 500?
Are you guys...
I'm sorry.
I know you guys want a regular life again.
I'm so sorry.
I...
I'm sorry.
I'm worried that I lose people.
Because...
I...
Everybody just...
All my fans disappear.
Guys, it's just six...
Guys, if I could finish it early...
Then it could technically be three days.
Guys, I could...
It could become three days.
If we get the best games of our lives.
We just need to be like...
We literally need to have secure.
We need to be like 200 points.
That's all we need.
200 points.
Just 200 points.
Surely we can get 200 points.
You guys are so far.
I don't know if I can.
There's a Psylocke above us.
I think... Goodbye.
Wait, that's huge.
Magnio's one.
Let's go.
Hey, let's go.
I'm sorry, everybody.
I know you guys want regular streams again.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm killing my career.
I'm just playing Minecraft.
Oh my god.
I can't stop.
Starting off strong in 2025 with career sabotage.
Starting it off strong by sabotaging my career.
I'm moving up a little bit.
Wait, wait.
Strange is low.
Strange has ult too.
This is a regular stream.
Psylocke, Psylocke on me.
There's a Psylocke behind Magnio's.
Yay!
No one's got me.
I know Rivals got me.
How'd I lose you, man?
I could do a regular stream like...
It ends next week, guys.
Literally, just please wait for me for one more week, guys.
Please.
Guys, just wait for me for one more week, guys.
And then...
And then it'll be okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm killing my career with this Marvel Rivals brain rot in the beginning of the year.
But guys, please just stay strong.
Stay strong.
I don't like...
Please.
My career can't end in 2025.
My career...
I want more Marvel Rivals.
The strongest fanbase.
I'll even stream Rivals at decent hours too.
I'll even... I'll do it.
I swear to god, I'll do it.
You need Marvel... Jesus.
IE Baby, what a name.
Thank you for the Twitch prom.
Thank you, thank you.
Lewis, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Hat and Gloves, thank you for the $10 donation.
Thank you, thank you.
Marvel Rivals streams are peak content.
Keep at it.
We love watching those.
Yeah, but they're like, you know...
I even said like, guys, you shouldn't stream only one thing all the time.
And then there's me.
Just six more days.
It's just six more days, everybody.
We can be strong for six more days.
Please.
Please give me six more days and then we'll be there.
I believe.
Look.
Naughty boy.
The fuck?
Don't you do it.
Why?
Oh.
That's why.
That's why they were naughty.
Aki, thank you for the Twitch prom.
Thank you, thank you.
And Purp and Nemesis, thank you for the bitties.
YouTuber fanbase of the year ain't losing to Marvel Rivals.
Oh, hey.
Hello is unlocked.
Any...
Any hello players?
Any hellos?
Hello players?
Any... No?
That's cool.
We don't need hello.
We don't need her.
Hello?
Hello, hello?
No?
It's alright.
We don't need hello.
Hello is for pussies, right?
We don't need her.
Superpowers are amazing.
Marvel Rivals has a moon and Dookie Bird is one of them.
They'll be coming in 30 seconds.
The actual Magneto.
Guys, I thought you were supporting me.
What happened?
Isn't it should be like, if Dookie Bird has a... Guys, wait.
I thought you guys would support me.
It blew my face.
Alright, have a seat.
Boom!
Now I have 20 seconds.
Oh, fuck.
This match starts in 5 seconds.
Oh!
Already throwing.
Alright.
It's fine.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Oh.
I need to give it to our flankers.
That's very unfortunate.
What the fuck?
Where did she come from?
I didn't even know she existed until now.
Alright.
I froze Magneto.
Magneto is not frozen anymore.
Alright.
Woah.
You taught me offenses?
It's fine.
I don't know what's going on, but it's okay.
I think he's doing it.
I think they're doing it, guys.
Wait, there's a Loki behind.
I got the Loki clone.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Is this strange pushing me?
That's alright.
That's okay.
We're being pushed up right now, but that's okay.
That's so okay.
Our tank just needs to push up just even a little bit.
Really?
That's really it?
Alright.
Woah!
That's fine.
Play on cart again.
Alright.
There's Magneto behind.
Oh!
They have strange ult.
And we don't really have anything for that, so...
Let's hope everything will be okay!
I'll give it to...
Oh, I was gonna give it to her Fister, but that's alright.
I can't give it to her Fister, so that's alright.
Strange is looking for an ult.
He's to our left!
He's looking for it.
Oh my god.
I can't help you over there, Mantis.
They're gonna strange ult after this.
He's looking for it!
He's looking for it now!
I froze him!
He's won!
Oh my god!
Sick freeze!
Nobody's gonna see it, so I compliment myself.
Guys, please boost my ego.
That was actually a fucking crazy freeze right there.
Guys, where is my ego boosters?
Where?
Guys, I need my chat to be like, wow, that was fucking sick, Doki.
Wow, you basically saved the game!
Wow, that's great!
Nobody's gonna compliment me for that!
That's fucking fine.
Heroes don't need compliments.
Whoa, huge freeze!
Thank you.
Thank you, I really needed that.
That's a huge ult, huge ult for my Shade.
I got you.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting this.
Play on point, you can.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I froze Hela!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, strangers low, strangers half!
I need heals.
I need heals really bad.
Oh my god!
Can we touch cart?
Oh, goodbye, strange.
Fucking bye!
Oh my god.
So close.
I just got my ult too.
That fucking sucked.
I literally just got my ult.
Oh my god.
It was so close.
Jesus Christ, our poor Black Panther.
I don't wanna stand next to them.
Oh my god, please.
They're just pushing up.
They're just free pushing it.
We can push up with this, help our Hela.
Please.
Okay, I'm ulting this.
I'm gonna play near cart.
Please, please!
Push near!
Oh my god!
Not Magneto!
Why are ticks so push back?
Why are ticks not fucking push close together?
I don't understand.
Why are ticks just fucking give up?
Like...
Just go up!
Wait, push up with that, push up with that.
Please.
Nice.
Oh my god, we finally pushed up.
We finally...
We finally pushed up.
That's fucking crazy.
We actually played up.
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
I'm so proud of all of you.
Like, you guys did the bare minimum of what a tank should be able to do.
Isn't that insane?
Holy fuck!
The absolute bare minimum of a tank player.
Oh, they should have strangled here.
Unless they used it.
Wait, unless they used it.
Actually, I don't think they used it.
Nevermind.
I forgot.
Oh my god, I'm fucking getting my ults confused.
They should have magic ult here.
Oh no!
No, I
couldn't!
Oh my god.
Oh, you can mantis ult first.
Jesus Christ.
We can push up with mantis ult, can't we?
Let's do it!
Push with this, push with this!
Oh, hell is one, hell is one!
Uh, strange, strange, strange.
We might be able- if we push up, they can't touch.
Are they TPing?
We can get rid of TP.
TP.
Yeah, see?
Woo!
I love how you run for your life every time.
Like, what else can I do?
I can't freeze him!
I can't, I can't, I can't fucking freeze him.
What the fuck do I do?
Like, he literally says fear magneto.
You fucking damn wrong with a fear magneto.
Just freeze the big metal ball.
I hear free magneto and I fucking run.
I just, I can't.
Bro, how is he 4-4?
I gave you orb!
She bravely runs away.
The orb does so much.
I'm gonna give it to plant.
I didn't realize he has orb.
What the fuck?!
Bro, these are some fucking hours.
This is the shot that ends the war, guys.
We're doing it again.
This is the rival that ends the war.
Oh, I shouldn't have clapped.
No, clapping early is fine.
Like, they were all lining up for it.
Anyway.
Hey, well done.
Oh my god.
You guys, you guys take way too much damage.
Yes, actually.
Holy shit, that damage was insane.
I'm just gonna orb the tanks, like, fuck this.
Like, they take way too much damage.
Grit's low.
Nevermind.
Hey, Grit, go!
Holy shit!
Oh, magic saw me.
Grit's low, Grit's half.
Jesus Christ!
I don't know if I should ult, though, because we don't have any defensive ults, so it's scarier.
It's a lot scarier.
Come on, Grit.
I'm ulting.
Oh, they have health.
Jesus Christ, Grit, Grit, Grit, Grit, one!
Grit, one!
my God.
Stop, fear!
No!
We're all grouped together.
Oh, my God.
Truth, fear, oh, my God.
There was the fear.
There was the... I told you guys.
Fear Magneto.
I told you.
Guys, this is not looking so great.
Magneto's one.
Oh, my God, there was someone that was low.
Oh, my God.
There's so... Grit, Grit, Grit, Grit, Grit, one, Grit, one.
Grit's low.
Focus Grit, please.
Oh, thank God.
There's a Magik behind me.
I had to ult.
There's a Magik behind.
Magik on cart, Magik on cart.
Oh, my God.
I have no ult for Grit ult, so we gotta be careful.
We can have four on cart, maybe.
I'm gonna try and freeze.
Oh, no!
Careful Grit ult here.
He's coming over.
Magneto's one.
I froze Magik behind me.
Find the heals.
Oh, my God.
Alright.
Yippee.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the huge freeze.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
Nobody else will compliment.
I'll push up.
Can you stay on cart?
Alright.
Here we go.
There's a Hella up top.
Oh, my God.
Please.
That tree was so fucking scary.
Nice.
Hella, hella, hella, hella.
Oh.
I'm stuck back here.
That's fine.
I get to be alive.
I can push up.
I have ult here.
Wait, what?
I'm ulting.
Just group up around me.
I'm pushing up with my ult.
Okay, I'm backing out in two.
Oh, please.
Group, group, group.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I'm trying my best.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying.
All I do is heal.
Oh, my God.
Where are we?
Oh.
There's a magic behind you guys.
There's one.
Can we have, like, three on cart at least?
Or four.
That's the max speed.
I can try and freeze someone.
They might have a chance to touch.
Oh.
Frozen, frozen, frozen, frozen, frozen, frozen.
No.
McNeil's one.
Gryff's low, too.
Gryff's low.
Gryff's one.
At him.
At him, mommy.
Oh, my God.
I didn't use it.
Bro, why did no one look at magic after I freeze her?
Why does no one ever look?
Uh, Mantis, you can push up for heals.
I already have my ult.
Again.
Spacer support.
Move, move, move.
Nice.
Ah!
I'm alive!
Bitch!
Oh, Gryff, Gryff, Gryff, Gryff.
That's nice.
That's good.
I'm gonna ult this.
I'm gonna ult this and push forward.
Ult this and push forward.
Yay!
We did it!
Oh, my God.
Didn't pat my Wolverine, though.
I know I feared Magneto.
I literally ran.
I ran like a little bitch every time.
I...
Fucking fuck Magneto, bro.
Oh, my God.
This is actually painful games right now.
These games are so fucking painful.
I could've...
If I didn't get like 15 earlier and actually got 20, I could've fucking got my Eternity back.
I could've got it back.
I keep like a list of people that are Eternity and GMs, but I just keep them there, because I don't know who they are.
Oh, I know this guy!
If you get Eternity back, I'll put you on my friends list.
But you're doom queuing, so I'm sorry.
Oh, Mac.
Oh, no.
Oh, we're all suffering.
Oh, that's so fucking rough.
He was Eternity for one game.
That's so rough.
Misery.
Oh, the actual misery there.
Misery loves comfort.
No, I do not!
I do not.
Oh, he's going through it.
I'm sorry, Mac.
The doom queue is upon you.
I'm sorry.
It's a doggy.
Dog world.
Oh, we're queue dodging, apparently.
You can stop the doom queue.
There's still time.
I can't.
It's too late for him.
It's too late.
He fucking mentally imploded and picked Black Panther and then yelled at our other... and then yelled at their team.
At that point, I was like, there's no saving you anymore, Mac.
It's too late to...
Even when I was like, Mac, can you play Starlord?
And Mac was like, and Mac was just like, it's not me.
And I'm like, oh.
We've lost him.
That's when I knew we lost him and I couldn't...
I couldn't save him no more.
0-7 the Mac.
I hope he...
0-7.
I hope...
I hope he recovers.
I really do.
I'm not Luna one trick.
It's just she's really good.
I swear I'm not Luna one trick.
She's just our best character.
I can play other characters.
I can play every support except for Loki.
Except for Loki.
Jeff is not in question.
Jeff is actually just...
See, I'm gonna prove it to you right now.
Alright, well, Luna's bad.
What?
Luna's bad?
Okay, that's alright.
No, Luna gets banned all the time.
I'm surprised this is the first Luna ban I've had.
Okay, just ban Bruce Banner if you don't want to play against Ironman.
It's literally that easy.
Bro, they banned me Ironman.
The fuck?
They really don't like Bruce Banner and Ironman.
They really?
Well, Moon Knight is good on certain maps.
It's the T'Challa map, the Wakanda one.
The Wakanda map's really good for...
Really good for...
This map again?
I feel like we haven't played any Ka.
We've just been playing Kart, Push.
We've just been playing Push maps.
Did I play one Ka game?
Oh yeah, I did.
I remember now.
I remember playing one Ka game.
No, they heard me.
They heard me because Kendrick Lamar fucking pushed up when I said go up and do support ults.
Everybody else just acknowledged me as the spokesperson of the team.
3... 2...
1!
Hey, we won.
Oh,
there's somebody behind us?
Or is that Black Panther behind?
Oh no, it's Venom.
Haha, JK.
Oh, Venom's low.
Venom won.
Alright.
There's one.
Oh my gosh.
I don't have heals right now.
Oh my god.
I'm trying my best.
Venom's low.
Venom's high.
Oh my god, please.
Damage!
You don't need heals.
Oh, I wish I could heal you right now.
I don't have heals right now, sorry.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, please.
I'm trying my best to keep you up.
Oh, Venom's low.
Venom's low.
I'm going with this.
I'm going up.
Push up.
Strange is half.
Oh my god.
Venom behind.
Venom half.
They're going to strange all after this.
Oh, Venom's asleep.
Rocket one.
Oh my god.
Black Panther.
Black Panther on me.
He's low.
He's half.
Oh my god, please.
He's one.
They're to the right.
Rocket raccoon one.
No, he's so low.
I'm going to beat you up.
I'm going to kick you.
I'm going to kick this raccoon in the...
Oh my god, please.
I'm going to run.
I'm going to fucking kick you.
That's fucking right.
Venom right.
Venom asleep.
That was a bit excessive.
Venom one.
Please.
We need to push these guys.
Yeah, we're up three.
We can push them.
Hello one.
I didn't really know he was one.
I just say it so people will know.
They have strange all.
He's looking for it.
He has shields broken.
We back up for that?
Yeah, I'm backing up.
Oh no, I couldn't get you.
Oh no.
I can use my mantis ult aggressively.
Jesus Christ.
I'm running out of leaves.
You think you can damage boost me?
Wait, who said that?
Hella.
Okay, yeah, I can.
I'll melt this.
Alright, I damage boosted you.
Back to number one.
Push up with that.
Our Hella is creating space.
Push up, push up, push up.
Rocket low.
Rocket one.
Strange half.
Nice!
Black panther.
Back to panther.
He's half.
He's one.
He's actually one.
Strange is pushing up.
He's one.
He's low.
He's so low.
Hella.
Oh, he has C9.
I have a magic on me.
She's asleep though.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they all chase me.
They C9 as fun as C9.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the red.
Thank you.
Oh, there's two people to your left.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Why is there so many people?
Hello everybody.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm here doing a Marble Rivals grind because I hate myself.
It's fine.
Oh shit.
Are you damage boosted, Hella?
Wait, Black Panther one?
She's so low.
Oh, sorry Hella.
Sorry, Hella.
There was no way to save you there.
They're using everything.
Yeah, we don't need all here.
Alright.
Buddy, I...
We're coming back.
No!
Are they portaling?
What?
What is that?
Oh shit, there's a Black Panther on me.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's so...
No, he's one.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I have all here.
That's alright.
I'm missing my sleeps though.
I need to get my sleeps up.
He's...
I'm saving my sleeps for him, but I'm missing.
That's the only problem.
I'm saving it.
But I'm... Black Panther, I'm ulting this.
I'm pushing, and we can push up.
I'm asleep.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
We're even.
Hella has ult though.
I'm burning.
I'm trying to burn Hella.
Oh no!
Now the magic pushed up!
Oh!
I have 10 seconds left to push.
Oh no!
I'm dead!
We can't!
Oh no!
I'm missing my sleeps.
Oh, I'm missing my sleeps on him.
I need to focus up on the sleeps.
Alright, I'm locking in.
I'm fucking locking in.
His dash, he times it so well.
Holy shit.
I'm literally...
I'm missing my...
My sleeps.
So I need to lock in here.
He's literally like...
Dodging all my...
He dodges all my sleeps every time I try to...
I shoot the ground, but he's on the other side by the time.
So I gotta...
I gotta fucking get better at that.
This is a really good Black Panther.
I'm like fucking struggling against him.
Woo!
Alright.
Okay.
There we go.
Thank you for the raid again!
I really appreciate it!
I literally...
The sleeps!
If I don't miss the sleep, it would've been so...
Oh my god.
I could shut him down.
But like...
He's literally dashing through all of them.
It's actually crazy.
He's really good.
Like, he's actually really good.
Which is surprising.
Oh my god.
This is scary.
I don't want to waste it too.
Trying not to waste my heals too much.
Should we start left?
Panther to left!
He's asleep!
He's one!
He's solo!
There you go.
I'm locked in.
Oh my god.
I don't have enough leaves!
Careful, Strange.
We can heal you.
Right now.
Oh my god.
Please!
I need like...
He's asleep!
Oh my god.
See, now I'm hitting it.
I'm hitting those sleeps!
But I don't have enough sleeps for everything!
To your left.
Top left.
Asleep.
Asleep, Magic.
Magic's low.
Magic's one.
I don't have ult yet.
Oh, Strange half.
Mantis is low too.
Oh my god.
I'm so locked in.
I told you guys!
Figuring... I know what he's thinking.
I'm in his mind.
I'm in his fucking mind now.
Oh my god.
I don't see anything.
Nice.
Oh, be careful guys.
Alright.
I told you!
I'm in his head!
You should have Magical here.
And Black Panther ult.
Help with Strange.
This is fine.
Oh, Strange.
Magic's low.
Come on.
Penny.
Penny one.
It's huge.
I'm gonna ult.
I'm ulting this.
Focus on Magic if we can.
I just left him.
Oh, nevermind.
Help with Strange.
I don't have heals anymore.
Nice.
Careful.
I slept him.
One.
He's one.
Wolverine.
Wolverine half.
Wolverine low.
I'm out of position.
I might be dead here.
Madness is one.
If you can heal me Loki.
We can might be contestant.
I actually don't know.
Nevermind.
Back up.
Oh my god.
There's a Wolverine to our left.
We need to push up soon.
I don't have any leaves.
I'm pushing.
I'm pushing up for her.
Go.
They also support ulti.
Be careful.
They have Wolverine ult.
They're gonna have Wolverine ult soon.
Nice.
We're even.
Strange is half.
Strange is low.
Nice.
We're up one.
I'm focusing on Strange.
Strange is half.
Strange is one.
No more ults.
We win this.
Oh, nevermind.
I'm on Mantis.
Mantis low.
We should fight the spawns.
Help our Strange.
I don't have heals anymore.
Yo.
I didn't have leaves.
Sorry.
No more.
Can you peek me?
Second damage.
They have Wolverine ult still.
Nice pick.
That's a huge pick.
Oh, we're down one.
We're down one.
Oh, we're even.
Wolverine is still looking for ult.
Left side.
Left side is Hella.
Oh, no.
We can try and stabilize with this.
Hella is still left.
I can't peek that.
She's dead.
Oh, shit.
Oh, magic low.
Magic low.
I'm stuck here.
I might be dead.
I got Hella, though.
Get on her.
I can't.
I'm on point.
I'm on the... Strange just got ult after this.
Oh, I just got ult, too.
If you guys can live, I can hop in.
Oh, shit.
I don't think so.
Just give it away.
I just got ult.
That sucks.
If I didn't... Oh, my God.
I literally... If I could have lived for one second longer, we could have fucking lived there.
Wait, Wolverine's low.
Oh, no.
That sucks.
I can save our strength there.
Go, Penny.
Go, go, go.
Oh, my God.
I can't do anything about it.
I should have ulted faster if I knew he was gonna... Oh, my God.
That was unlucky.
That was a good ult.
Yeah.
That was unlucky.
I ulted...
I ulted to try and save our Strange, but he... It was too late.
His kidnap was too far.
The kidnap was too fucking far.
Yeah, his kidnapping was too much for us.
That had ult for the choke point for a while?
I don't know.
Did I actually?
Which choke point?
Like the... Wait, did I?
Oh, my God.
I must have...
Yeah, I must have tunneled.
I must have fucking tunneled then.
I didn't know that.
I thought I...
I thought I just got it because the Hella and Magic were pushing me.
So I was just like, okay.
Because I had to... I had to fucking fight off the Hella by myself and then the Magic came up.
Oh, if I...
Yeah, I didn't realize because I knew I didn't have ult.
I didn't know the Hella kill gave me ult.
No, I was getting pushed by Hella, Magic, and Wolverine.
So I was just like, okay.
And I like broke down.
I was just like, alright.
I literally had like...
Had like support tunnel vision because I was getting... I was getting fucking ran at.
I was so scared.
That's fine.
I make mistakes.
It happens.
I don't know which part is like...
When you Q with like a GM's replay, the loss is fucking...
Fuck, man.
Yeah, but okay.
I locked... I fixed the sleep problem though.
I literally fixed the sleep problem.
I was like, I'm not sleeping, people.
And then round two, I locked in and I started sleeping people again.
I was like, there you go.
There you go.
I fixed it.
I did.
I literally...
I literally fucking... I shut them down so hard.
I literally shut them down.
Trick and Kendrick in the same game.
True.
Yeah, but Leah, what are the odds?
How long have I been streaming anyway?
Why don't I just put a 30 second ad?
Why don't I just do it?
I'm gonna do it.
30 second ads, guys.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
Guys, you know how to avoid ads?
If you subscribe.
Do it, coward.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I did it.
And then I lose like five...
I lose like a thousand viewers from that.
Sorry, I got unsubbed, guys.
I got unsubbed.
Oh my god, I finally get a cough map.
Jesus Christ.
I feel like I haven't played cough in so long.
I won't sell out.
That's right.
I sell out like once every 20 years.
Jeff.
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna fucking have a heart attack.
I don't even know what that...
You know, I could put a fucking six minute ad on there.
You're welcome.
Alright.
Oh, Venom.
I never see Venoms in my games until...
Well, actually...
Only Scrap in Rust Kingdom?
Who's this guy?
Who's Jumpman?
I owe people a lot of stuff.
They gotta be specific.
Oh, I don't know why I clapped.
That was reflex, because usually the tank is in front of me.
Like...
Usually, I would have a tank in front of me.
And then, you know...
My clapping would be very smart.
But like...
Where did my tank go?
What?
Oh my god.
Is there a penny on us?
Fuck.
I'm waking you up.
I'm waking you up right now.
Oh my god.
I'm frozen too.
It's fine.
We capped it.
It was a bit late.
I literally do that with reflex.
Like...
Just clap the moment I get to there.
Because usually...
There would be like 20...
There would be like...
You know, my tank is in front of me.
So it would make sense for me to start clapping.
So I can do like...
Absolutely crazy heals.
So I was just like...
Where did they go?
Where did my tanks go?
Where are they?
Where did they go?
We can do Mantis ult first.
I'm dead.
Alright.
Is this...
Is this Numbuh?
I...
Alright.
I don't know how...
I don't know how they die.
Alright.
That was strange as hell.
No more, no more, no more, no more, no more.
Oh my god.
Oh, Penny ult, Penny ult.
Alright, nice.
We did it, everybody.
Strange as hell right now.
I'll try...
If he flies up in the air.
I don't know.
If he...
He stays alive if it's so easy.
Just CC him.
Oh, I'm dead, I'm dead.
There's a magic on me.
There's a magic still on me.
Please, magic's one.
Please.
You have no heals, you have no heals.
Just get health packs if you can.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please, get him.
Oh my god, they're all crying.
Oh, Penny off the map.
No more is low, Manor's half.
No more, no more.
Manor.
You can get magic, push magic if you can.
Magic's half.
Magic's one, magic's one.
Spider, Penny's low, Penny half.
Luna, Luna, Luna, focus Luna.
Bro.
I just saw him pull.
That poor Penny.
I swear, we lost that because he did that pull.
I swear to god.
They should have both tank ults here.
They should.
Still has...
Alright.
You can ult first, Mantis.
Alright, this still has four ults.
Woah, this is gonna be...
This is gonna be something, that's for sure.
How did that work?
I don't...
I don't fucking...
Damn.
Venom and Spiderman.
Venom.
Get off the bed.
That guy's like, get off the bed.
To me.
And he's like, alright, there we go.
That's what we wanted.
Right there.
That was like a fucking hell, man.
Oh my god.
Okay, I don't think we should use anything here.
I don't...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, Mantis, they still have strange ult.
I can try and save bubble for them.
That was a...
Oh my god, Mantis, please.
Please, Mantis.
You are scaring me right now.
Can you top me off, Mantis?
I'm behind you.
I'm ulting it.
I'm gonna try and get the mines here.
I didn't say try!
Oh my god.
That's a lot of damage.
Oh, there's a magic on me.
If you win this, you should be even.
Because we killed three.
Our Mantis is back.
Yeah, they used both supports.
Mantis should be 50 to next ult.
Oh, they're pushing us.
They're gonna strange ult after that.
He's looking for it.
He's afk.
There's a penny to our left.
There's a penny frozen to our left.
Can you peek me?
Mantis, Mantis, look at me.
Oh, I'm ulting this.
Fight next to me.
Oh, that's fine.
You're so healthy.
Oh, not you though.
Not you.
Some of you will be healthy and some of you...
Oh my god.
I think we should just die.
I'm holding a can.
I'm sorry.
I had to pick one or the other.
You guys were so split up.
What else am I gonna do there?
We can walk all the way around.
Mantis behind us, Mantis behind us.
I need help.
Oh, that was last fight.
That was last fight.
We should win next fight.
They're gonna have to go.
I need... I need somebody to help me.
It's okay.
No help.
I don't need help.
It's okay.
No help.
I just need somebody to peel magic for me and then I'll be so safe.
I'll be so...
Guys, it's that easy.
If you peel the magic, I'd be...
I'd be like...
Yay!
Yippee!
I'd be like, yay!
I feel like you never have help as a heal...
That's what I'm saying!
Why do you think the quick play supports help each other?
Like...
Like,
that's why I was so mad!
Because I'm like, why do quick play supports actually help?
Why don't I get that?
I'm an eternity!
Not even tourney, I'm a GM one.
Sorry, I forgot.
I'm not there anymore.
Help her, Mantis.
I have a magic on me.
She's frozen.
Penny's low!
Penny's half.
Penny's low again.
Penny's one.
Please, she's actually one.
Can we try to get Luna?
Luna's low.
Luna's with her Venom.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
For those who don't know me, my name's Zoe, but I usually stream on YouTube.
But I'm here because I'm...
Just play all around me.
Oh, please play around me.
I dropped down!
He broke the platform.
I've frozen!
Oh my god, I can't save you all!
It's fine.
Yeah, I'll save it for Strangelove.
I just didn't know we were... I saw the magic and I fucking panicked.
So I put on the Spiderman first.
After dying to the magic so many times because I have no peel...
Of course I have PTSD from that shit.
Like...
Magic behind me, she's frozen again.
We're... we're up.
We're up two.
We're up here.
We're...
I froze Penny.
Nice, that's huge.
Magic, magic, magic!
Magic blow!
I have ult for a change.
Big stagger on them, I guess.
Alright.
Oh my god, that magic really fucking...
That's what I mean!
This is the only help I get!
Where's my Mantis?
That's literally the only help I get from my team.
I just...
I just have to... I have to... I freeze.
I freeze them.
Someone help our stream.
Oh, thanks, we can't heal you there.
I'm falling back, I'm falling back.
That's Mantis ult.
That's a huge ult, that's a huge ult!
Yeah, we can't fucking...
Alright, alright, alright.
The magic's on me, I'm not using ult here.
I'll die.
I got you, you bubble.
Oh, I'm dead though.
Alright, we got... we got...
Yeah.
Wait.
Wait, why did you swap off...
Why did you swap off Mantis?
Alright, here we go.
I either die without using my ult...
Or I win.
There's no in-between.
There's actual no in-between.
Which way are we going?
We're split up, we're split up.
Fucking that shit down.
They're portaling?
He's gonna ult.
Where are you guys?
I'm on the right.
This portal looks terrible.
Please,
fight Yana all you need to if you're low.
Oh, why did our team...
No more purple, no more purple.
Why did our team BS?
Please!
I did everything I'm supposed to do!
I didn't do this right!
Oh my god!
No!
Who's through?
Who did he save through?
I didn't even hear when he said that through.
Was it me?
I was literally told!
I was told to hold ult!
I literally...
What the fuck you...
He said I threw because I held ult...
Don't tell me to ult!
I was getting yelled at for...
I was getting yelled at for ulting against magic.
Because you're like, save your ult through.
Save your ult through.
Stop ulting against magic.
And I was like, okay, I'll fucking hold my ult against strange.
Like, what?
I literally had to defend myself against magic...
Every time.
By freezing her.
And my match was never with me.
Like...
If only they helped.
If only they helped me against the magic.
Then I wouldn't fucking have to always deal with the magic myself.
Yeah, it's like...
You didn't save your ult.
They're like, alright, magic's on me.
Fucking help me, I'm holding my ult.
They're like...
Why are you ulting against fucking magic?
I'm like, okay, I'll stop ulting against magic.
That's crazy.
Yeah, our Spiderman said I threw.
Because they were yelling at me for not using my ult against strange.
Because I basically used my defensive against the first person that aggressed ult me.
And then they're like, stop using your ult against magic.
So I was like, okay.
And then they're like, why'd you threw by holding your ult against magic?
And I'm like, oh...
Fuck you.
That's so...
That's so bravo.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Doki Bird.
But I usually stream on...
I usually stream on...
I haven't found a good tank player to fucking kidnap yet.
It's so hard to find good tank players to kidnap.
I'm not... I'm never trusting...
I should've trusted my intuition.
I wanted to ult against that magic, but I didn't want to get yelled at again.
So...
That's why I didn't... I didn't want to...
I was worried I was going to get yelled at again.
So I didn't ult against that magic.
There's a Spiderman on me?
Yeah, he's up.
There's more than one up top.
Where you're going.
That's why I was like, oh.
I don't know what to do.
I'm just going to trust my intuition.
I'm not going to let people control where I ult.
There's another Spiderman again.
He's frozen.
Both supports are on point.
He's low.
Spiderman's behind us again.
Oh my god.
I'll just come hold your hand or whatever you're trying to do.
Spiderman's behind again.
Oh my god, please.
I can't.
Spiderman's distracting us.
Clap.
I'm just using my clap for DPS.
Oh, nice.
And you can ult whenever.
Oh, to your right.
There's a Strange.
Strange is half.
Strange is low.
Spiderman's behind us again.
Oh my god.
There's so many.
Please.
Ah!
I'm ulting this.
Please.
Kill anybody.
Ah, guess not.
Oh shit, nice.
Oh, there's a Spiderman still behind us.
Strange walking up to me.
I'm gonna die here.
There's...
We need somebody to peel for Spiderman because our Mantis is getting distracted by him.
Oh my god.
Fucking...
Strange, please!
I can't heal you forever!
You get a weapon!
Oh, skip.
That's cool.
This is...
Spiderman behind us again.
He's one.
Please.
I can't keep you up forever.
I'm dead here.
I can't.
You're falling apart.
No, I don't do the Luna tech because it's bugged.
People keep thinking it's a really good tech because it looks cool but it loses games more than it wins games.
I saw a streamer do it so I'm pretty sure it's a good tech but it's not.
There's a Spiderman behind again.
What's the tech?
Basically...
You can damage and heal over and over but it can bug out to the point where...
I'm on their Mantis.
What?
Why didn't that hit?
Was it because I was in the air?
It like pulled up on my screen.
Alright, goodbye.
Alright.
Here we go.
There's a Spiderman on our Mantis.
He's gonna auto-mote us.
Can it though?
Can it really die?
Can he literally...
Die, please!
Oh my god!
Someone just killed a Spiderman!
It actually heals less than it damages too.
If you guys don't know that.
The Luna tech, it heals less than it damages.
Because people think it does more heals than damage but it actually doesn't.
So people can actually kill through the Luna ult because of that tech.
And also it can bug out and stay on damage.
So there's way too much risk.
There's way too much risk with it than their actual benefits.
Because I've lost two games when when the tech was first came out, I actually lost two games from it.
That's why I don't do it anymore.
I did it for like two days.
The first day, it was great.
It felt great.
And then the second day I realized it was not so great.
It looks cool though.
Yeah, it looks so cool.
Yeah, that happens.
The Namor's up top.
Kill the Namor bullshit.
Their Namor's half.
I'm about to try and shit at him.
I'm gonna look here but you're not gonna be able to shoot this ult.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Alright, I don't know why.
I'm so dead, I'm so dead.
We have one fight here.
We have one fight, that's fine.
Spiderman's ruined actually.
He's trying to pull somebody off.
Okay.
Nice.
We got him.
I stood in the door cause I knew I would not survive.
I knew damn well I was not gonna survive that.
Put on the storm just cause like he has to.
Oh no.
There's a strange right behind us.
Fire!
I'm gonna die to the Spiderman.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
Nobody peels for him.
We called out the Spiderman every time.
Everybody just ignores him.
I don't understand.
Why nobody looks at him.
Like, we look at him and then we don't put the...
Oh my god, this is actually crazy.
No one looks at the Spiderman.
I call him out every time.
Like, he's behind us.
There he is.
I'll keep it real.
As terrible as that wet, this is still wittable.
Like, there he is.
What do we do?
Somebody will take care of it.
Who's that somebody?
Who could it be?
Clearly it's not me.
Spiderman doesn't kill.
What the fuck is he doing here?
What is he doing?
I don't know.
If my team actually kills the Spiderman, then like, Spiderman's here.
Bye Spiderman.
Behind us?
Okay, I didn't think that's where he was gonna go.
Not gonna lie.
That changes half.
Did he go back?
Oh my god, he did.
I'm scared.
He don't see you.
He's gone.
Spiderman behind you.
I hope you're fucking shooting the Spiderman!
Because I have the healing!
I don't have like...
Oh my god.
I don't have the privilege to look!
I can ult in.
Alright, I'm gonna ult in.
Oh shit!
Oh!
Alright!
Here we go.
And then I die here.
Oh shit.
Is our Storm actually throwing?
Now?
Oh my god, I don't think he knows I stream.
This is a fucking idiot.
Now everybody knows I'm a streamer and you're a thrower.
You're on a list.
You're on a fucking list now.
Oh shit.
This guy's gonna be on my fucking list now.
It's always funny when people don't know I'm like a streamer in their name and they like actively throw as if there's like no consequences just for streaming.
That's so embarrassing too.
If they have TTV in their name and they do that.
That's actually so fucking embarrassing for you.
Like what's your expectation gonna be?
Alright, I'm gonna avoid this guy.
Pretty hilarious.
Dune game.
Literally, it's Dune because like nobody, like literally everybody it's crazy.
I don't know why some TTVers like some TTVers are like that.
Like they put TTV in their name but they have like the most shittiest reputation.
Like like the thing is like I'm gonna report you too.
Throwing um AFK'd and threw himself off off a cliff in game.
Like is that really, do you really want that to be your reputation?
Especially when like you're streaming and I'm streaming too.
Like it's crazy, like I'm not a huge streamer.
Yeah, I'm not like well known in the FPS scene.
I'm also a support player and I'm a VTuber.
Or not TPS, a shooter scene outside of like VTubing but still it's like, it's funny when they don't know I'm a streamer and they like do shit like that in front of everybody and it's like bro you're just embarrassing yourself.
Like you're just embarrassing yourself.
It's so fucking cringe.
It's actually cringe.
5.8k people like watch him fucking be a little baby.
Actual little baby man.
Like if you just fucking play the game it's literally three minutes of your life.
It's three minutes of your fucking life, play the game.
It's not that hard.
Do I have any tank players online right now?
I only have like, I don't know actually.
I haven't found a tank player I want to adopt.
They're all like mediocre.
I don't want to talk anymore, I'm too sad.
I don't want to talk in game anymore I'm too sad now.
These have been some some fucking queues.
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
These games have been sad.
Holy shit!
The three hella Jesus Christ, that was so fast.
Oh my god.
You thirsty dogs.
Luna's banned, what do you mean?
Luna banned.
OG.
They know what they want.
They know exactly what they want.
What do you mean I played Mantis?
That's like, that's actually crazy.
Luna's like, really banned.
Has been like, not banned for a while.
So when you see me online, prof can prove, okay get on.
Okay get on.
Right now.
You wanna fucking say that?
Get on!
I'll fucking lose your eternity right now.
Perfect timing.
I thought you were a Hulk one trick.
And Hulk is banned 20%.
This is like some guy I found in rank matchmaking.
And I was like, I think it was like the first GM player I saw.
And then he like, added me and I was like, okay.
This is crazy, honestly.
I am trying to give you my leaves.
Back when GM was like, still super rare, you know?
Like when GM was still like, incredibly rare.
And I was still like, a filthy diamond player.
Let me, let me give head.
Sorry, that's so bad out of context.
You know exactly.
I need that headshot.
There we go.
Let me headshot you.
Jesus Christ, get this mine off me.
That's fine.
Head.
Ayo.
Hit.
Oh, he's so low.
I'm not comming this game, I'm sad.
Teams have been way too sad.
They don't deserve comms anymore.
There we go.
Fuck it.
They're not even pushing, like, I don't care.
I'm just gonna kill this guy.
Alright, we don't have support out for like, actual important things.
If that's- I got too- Ow!
I'm alive.
Oh no.
Goodbye.
I got sad, so no more talking in game until I feel better.
Until I feel good about myself.
Ever since that guy yelled at me being like, you threw the game because you held up, but then I was like, what do you want from me?
I get yelled at for ulting, and I get yelled at for not ulting.
Oh my god.
What do you want from me?
There's no winning, I'm just a- There's no winning, I'm gonna beat you up!
Don't let it get to you.
I'll remember that guy's name forever.
Hella is open and they're willingly playing Squirrel!
Ever since that- All it takes is one bad day, chat.
That's all it takes, guys.
That's all it takes.
Where's my- I'm a support player!
We don't have egos!
We're too sad to have egos.
We're literally too fucking sad.
Lies.
Except for Rocky Raccoons, because I have no idea how the fuck Rocky Raccoon players have egos.
You literally have no hands playing him.
No, Loki players don't have egos.
Loki players are fucking actually...
They're chads.
A good Loki player is very scary.
Because like, if they're playing Loki when there's so many other supports they could play, like Loki is really difficult to master too.
That's why I feel like Loki players are like, they're making their life harder for themselves playing a very difficult character.
Because like, it requires a lot of thinking in general, on how to play Loki.
Like right now, I'm literally just, I damage boost, I heal up, I do this.
But Loki, you gotta like, think You gotta like, think a lot.
Did I get off?
I did.
Nice.
You know what?
Fuck you too.
That's fucking right.
I'm not over.
I'm not done.
I'm not fucking done with you.
That's fucking right.
This is not ego, this is literally just me doing my job.
It's me, it's me doing my job.
That's not an ego.
Come on, give me, give me your headshots.
Nice, thank you.
That's all I ask.
I realized that Starlord has not ulted.
Oh.
There he goes.
Wait, where is he?
Oh.
There he goes.
Um, there he dies, I guess.
Is our Starlord okay?
He is.
How?!
What?!
I'm not using it.
Me?
Thank you for the 10 gifts!
Oh shit!
Oh okay, if I knew we were still going, I would not have...
Oh my god, I would have not...
Okay, we wait.
We wait here.
I wait here now.
Orca, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
I don't need to explain who I am to you guys.
If you came from Orca's stream.
Panther?
Panther, what the fuck are you doing?
Oh shit!
Map change!
Oh, I thought there was...
Nice.
Fuck you guys.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Alright, we still have to keep going.
Alright, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna eagle.
For once in my life, I'm gonna do it.
And this is why you don't eagle push.
This is why you don't have any...
Exactly why.
Hahaha.
I learned my lesson!
I learned my lesson everybody!
Jesus Christ.
Oh, he's looking for it.
He's looking for it right here.
He's looking for it!
Alright, I leave.
Yeah, I had a feeling he was gonna do that.
Yeah, I had a feeling he was gonna...
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Please, you have to live.
Please!
You have to live!
No!
Wait, do I...
Oh my god.
I'll respawn here.
I'll do it here.
Okay.
Can someone contest?
I have my ult.
Okay.
The map changed.
I love it when the map changed, guys.
Hahaha.
Are you serious?
He's so low!
Who woke him
up?!
Okay.
Please.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Go.
I will...
I'll beat him up too.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I am king.
I'm the king.
Oh my god.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Hell abuser freak.
Go find your father.
Okay.
Don't... Oh my god.
Wait, don't Q on me.
I'm so worried.
Oh, bro.
Alright.
Okay, there we go.
We have our...
We have our tank players.
Alright, here we go.
This is our tank player.
He has two games to impress us.
He has two games.
We give him two games.
Actually, we're holding tank auditions, guys.
What do you lose?
You lose member.
Guys, we're holding tank auditions right now.
So, like...
Alright.
Are you a tank player?
Oh, okay.
Okay, what's your win rate, though?
Guys.
Hahaha.
What's your tank?
Woah.
Oh my god.
Wait, but what happened here, though?
Tank auditions are now open.
It's like American Idol, but like Marvel Rivals Idol.
Yeah, you gotta warm up.
Oh, we're dodging?
I think we're dodging.
I mean, to be fair, that game was like a shit show.
So, like, I'm not surprised.
I'm gonna grab water real quick.
I'll be right back.
Maybe I won't.
You fucking...
You left!
What do you mean, Maze?
I've been streaming for five hours already.
What do you mean?
Hahaha.
It's too late.
This is Lao's first game.
If he...
I'm looking for a stack.
How bad could it be?
We would automatically get two tank players.
Oh my god.
We got a stack?
Can I pull up the full shroud?
Will he, like, force stack to 500?
That's the dream.
Honestly.
That's a...
That's a dream.
I don't even know what the queue times are.
Is there a downside?
Queue times?
But I don't know what the queue times are.
We could try force stacking.
We'll see how the queue times go.
Literally, VTuber shroud.
Hahaha.
VTuber shroud, but like, not even...
But like, what is it called?
Not even a dollar store.
Dollar store shroud.
Honestly.
Let's see what the queue time, estimated time is.
Alright, I'll stop queue.
We're gonna, we're gonna force stack.
Hahaha.
Fuck it, if people in top 10 are min-maxing, I'm gonna min-max bottom 10.
I'm gonna min-max GM1.
That justifies it for me.
That justifies it.
Hahaha.
Let's go.
I went through hell already.
It's fine.
I went through hell, it's alright.
Hahaha.
It's okay.
Who's gonna min-max bot?
I swear, if I like, lose this stack, I deserve to lose at this point.
Hahaha.
I actually deserve to fucking lose.
Like, that's the game telling me like, it's over for you, Doki.
Like, you're here forever.
It's like, you know how they like, turn on east coast?
Oh my god, we're doing it.
We're bringing east coast back.
We're fucking welcoming back the brethrens in east coast.
I mean, we're taking two east coast players, there's no way they cancel us out.
We're literally four to two.
We're four versus two easties.
There's no way they can cancel us out.
There's no- It means the enemy team has six east coast players.
Um...
Hahaha.
If I lose- No, we can't end stream until eternity.
We can't end stream.
The opponent- Exactly!
We'll have two east coast players, and then the opponent will have six east coast players.
That's like- It's like- It balances everything out.
We're so fine.
Hahaha.
It'll be okay.
Don't jinx it.
Oh my god, you know what?
Like, bro, I got yelled at today.
I'm- Hahaha.
When somebody yells at me, I crumble.
I'm like- I'm just- I'll just think about it and be like, why'd he yell at me?
Hahaha.
I'm the one that threw when the Mantis never supported me.
I can never move on!
No, this is why I- Okay.
No, I'll just give you guys- Why I never- I don't talk in game.
I was so desperate to climb when I started.
Uh, I haven't IG- Like, not- I don't talk at all for the longest time.
This literally broke- Marvel Rivals literally broke my zero-talking in-game streak because I was so desperate to win.
But in Overwatch, I was known as a shotcaller in Overwatch and, like, I was really, really good at it.
But then I got yelled at one time and then I never talked in game ever since.
Hahaha.
I had never- talked in game since because I got yelled at.
And then I never talked again in a game of randoms because I didn't like- I was just like, I'm sad.
I'm sad.
That's actual Overwatch PTSD.
It was Overwatch.
I got like- I don't mind if people are like misogynistic.
I mean, okay, like, it's not that I don't mind.
Like, I can take that.
Like, I can take people being misogynistic.
But, like, what I can't take is people, like, saying I threw the game or, like, because of something I did or, like, calling me shit.
Not because I'm a woman.
I- hahaha.
I care.
But, like, I can take misogyny because it's like, alright, they're just fucking stupid, you know?
But then when they hurt me via, like, skill-wise, skill-wise, it's like, it hurts me even more.
Misogyny enabling.
I can handle- Yeah, I can handle make a sandwich over how did you threw the game.
It was all your fault.
Or, like, you're shocked.
Shut up, you're shotcalling terrible.
Or shit like that.
So, it's like, because I can laugh over- I can laugh at somebody trying to be, like, a woman hater.
But, like, I can't laugh at somebody calling me bad.
Yeah, skill issue is actually my kryptonite.
It actually is.
She identifies as a gamer first.
For real.
So, like, literally, I literally broke my, like, rank voice comm streak of, like, zero voice comms with randoms for, like, five plus years, I think.
I think, like, I haven't commed against- with randoms in four to five years.
And it's, like, this game broke the- like, two days ago, broke the streak because I was so fucking desperate to win.
I was- I was so desperate.
The three genders, male, female, gamer.
And then the next dude, and now I will never talk again because of that one Spider-Man player.
That one Spider-Man player.
That's now shutting me up for the next five years now.
No!
You chuckle nuts!
And then I thought it was supposed to be a friendly neighborhood Spider-Man!
What happened to the friendly?
What happened to him?
Alright, guys, if we don't get a game in, uh...
one more minute, because I'll be like- okay, no, I'll give you guys two minutes.
I'll give us a two-minute buffer.
I'm sorry, Lao, but I'm sorry, Lao.
We'll do- we'll- auditions might be over.
We'll go again.
We'll have Lao next time.
We'll have Lao next stream.
Lao might be the best player here.
I mean, better than me for sure.
No, no, he's right.
No, better than me.
I'm definitely not the best player in this team.
No.
We might- We might- Lao is the lucky charm.
We'll wait for you to queue it.
We played a few back.
Not sure yet.
Wait.
You gotta- Okay, but like, you gotta tell me like, what few back, though.
There's- Like, years ago?
Few back?
I know you were in my team with random characters.
I'm queuing in Marvel Rivals.
What if they kick me?
Guys, I'm- If they kick me out, who's gonna watch their games?
I'm literally the only one streaming right now.
If we- If they kick me out, you guys won't even be able to watch any of the games!
They're gonna be queuing and you can't even watch it!
Let's spectate them.
They're gonna -
They're just gonna spectate their fucking matchup.
Guys, it's about my rank roids!
What do you mean?
I'm the desperate one here!
I literally made a four stack!
Commitator, alright.
We watch part of their games and see if I'm the problem.
Guys, we all know that as a support player, we struggle the most.
Okay, when it hits the 10 minute mark.
Guys, alright.
10 minute mark.
We'll do 10 minute- I'm gonna up it up.
We'll do 10 minute mark.
Also, right away, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Prime sub for two months.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub.
No, I'm not doom queuing.
I swear to God, I'm- Oh my God, we fucking did it!
I swear if the enemy team is like the best fucking team in the fucking- Oh my God, it's Wavy!
Oh my- I swear if they get like- Oh my God, it's fucking Wavy.
Oh my God, I- It - Lau.
Lau, we lose to Wavy, Lau?
I'm fucking recruiting Wavy.
I'm freaking Wavy.
We lose to Wavy.
I'm auditioning Wavy.
I'm gonna audition him.
Alright, this is your audition.
Oh wait, last of Bruce.
I don't even know if I can battle, cause I know he's the Bruce mate.
This is your only chance.
This is both- Exactly, this is Lau and Wavy's audition.
Exactly.
Oh, they already banned Bruce Banner, that's fine.
We'll ban Helidon.
Titan and Wavy will pop off for sure.
No, I feel like Wavy, if you diff Lau, you win the audition.
Audition.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
Get down on the first game.
Wavy has to go against Mace.
Yeah, but like, Wavy is Wavy is like, um...
Oh my god, Mace on Adam.
Alright, let's do it.
Let's go.
No, it truly is.
Guys.
Guys, it truly is.
It basically is Lau versus Wavy now.
It really is.
Cause like, Wavy is also a tank player.
So like, it truly is.
Wait, what did he say?
It really is.
This is it.
This is your audition.
This is literally your audition right now, Lau.
Right here.
Right now.
Team Wavy or team Lau.
Put in your votes, guys.
Let's go.
What team are you guys on?
What team will you guys be on?
Oh, it's the Spiderman.
Oh my god, not the Spiderman.
What?
I'm scared.
Wait, there's a Spiderman behind me.
Spiderman one.
I'm just fighting on point again.
Oh my god.
We have such low heals.
Spiderman behind.
Nice.
That's fine.
Everything is so fine.
What's my rank right now?
Things were really rough.
We had some...
We had a lot of doom cures today.
Where's the squirrel?
Oh no, the squirrel is coming over.
I'm scared.
Oh my god, I'm ulting this.
Nice.
Oh, Matrix is asleep.
Okay, that's on you.
That's actually on you.
Spiderman half.
Oh my god, you guys are so low.
You guys are so low.
Oh my god.
I can't, I can't.
Spiderman behind us.
He's asleep.
I didn't rez him.
Oh, nevermind.
Goodbye.
Oh shit, he got a kill.
I could've rezzed.
Oh.
Nice, I'm damage boosting you.
We still win, we still win.
I got you healed.
Bye Wavy.
Damn.
I did that and then fucking left him with a signature.
Oh jeez.
Wait, is Spiderman behind me?
He's asleep.
I have no idea if they did anything with that Spiderman.
But like, I think they did it.
I think that Spiderman might touch.
Yeah, Spiderman's behind.
Someone's asleep.
Dream, dream, dream.
Dream's half, dream's one.
Oh wait, we got the point, it's fine.
I'm not ulting.
Oh, please.
Come on now, you've got this.
You've gotta outpig him.
This is your life.
We can walk out, we've got a safe here.
Come on.
That's right.
Fight for it.
Fight for your place in the V2 for Shroudstack.
I'm gonna push the cart now.
While I was doing it.
I can't heal you guys, I'm on cart.
Alright, Spiderman above.
Oh, wrong one.
My shield's broken, back up.
That's cool though.
You're so healthy.
Spiderman behind us, he's asleep.
He's one, Siren's one.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no.
I'm fucking pushing, no.
Oh, he's one.
Nice.
He's one.
Fight for your life!
Can we destroy this?
I don't think we can.
I'm gonna push this.
Oh my god.
I can't see you guys for heals.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Are you?
Is Spiderman on me?
Is he asleep again?
Oh, I sw- Oh my god, oh my god.
I swear to god, it's a Spiderman!
Oh, whoops.
I swear to fucking god.
I do everything I can to sleep this Spiderman and yet he lives.
Like, what's the point?
Actually, what's the point?
What the fuck is the point of his- What do I do?
Like, what do I do?
Oh, he's asleep.
I'm gonna push.
We're gonna push this.
Spiderman on me.
Oh, I like that.
Let him live.
I'm ulting.
Can we just have?
Oh, man, I'm one.
Is Spiderman on me?
Or am I still on me?
No!
Please!
How do I- How does the Spiderman keep living?
Now this ain't looking so good.
This ain't looking so good.
Wavy's MVP.
Ain't looking so good.
He's MVP.
Spiderman behind us.
Oh my god, where did he go?
There's so many pictures on my screen.
I can't tell where he went.
I don't wanna get missed by the amazing Spiderman.
We gotta reset.
Jay!
You're so alive!
Oh, I'm trying to keep you up, Jay.
Strange one, strange low.
Spiderman behind- Oh, Venom behind me.
Oh my god.
There's a Spiderman behind me again.
I might be dead to this.
Please.
I'm struggling because I can't even like-
Oh my god.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
Venom's half, Venom one.
Venom low.
Venom's still low.
I'm gonna- Spiderman, Spiderman, Spiderman.
I'm backing out a little.
That's fucking right!
3, 2, 0.
Finally!
The one- Oh my god, I slept in a million times and he's finally dead.
Finally dead.
It only took seven sleeps before my team actually killed him.
It really only took seven sleeps.
Oh my god, finally.
It's over.
It's actually over.
Literally every time.
Every fucking time.
Is Doki back to eternity yet?
Am I still streaming?
Am I still here streaming?
Whoa!
Let's stay on strange, yeah.
We're still here.
I'm turning to Eddie Brock in Spiderman 3.
No, I'm fucking- I'm not Eddie Brock, I'm JJJ.
I watch his podcast.
Somebody doc Spiderman now.
I don't want photos of Spiderman.
I want a doc Spiderman.
We don't have a lot of heals here, so...
I'm definitely- I'm down.
Jesus Christ.
I'm okay.
I have a magic on me now.
I have magic and Spiderman on me.
I'm just gonna down point.
Oh my god.
I need Spiderman social security number.
And you know where the Spiderman lives.
Where the fuck does he live?
Hahaha.
Okay.
Oh my god, that magic is so low.
Oh no.
Uh, magic sleep.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Please.
How many times?
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm messing with the amazing Spiderman.
Where did he go?
No, I don't want to mess with him anymore.
Please, how many?
How many times?
Get him out.
Holy fuck.
Somebody stop him.
Sorry.
Kill him with fire.
Somebody please.
Oh my god.
Spiderman is half.
Oh, I couldn't sleep it.
I saw it.
I saw it too and I couldn't sleep it.
I was so ready.
I had my shift key up.
And everything.
My shift key was up.
Oh my god, I run.
I run now.
Oh, this is awkward.
I don't even think we have enough heals for triple take.
Oh my god.
Spiderman to my left.
Guys, we don't have the heals for triple take.
They banned Luna.
If we had Luna, I would understand.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Honestly, if Luna wasn't banned, I would understand triple take.
So like, what do you want us to do at that point?
What do you want us to do?
Oh my god.
I can feel...
I can feel the Spiderman coming in.
He's so fucking ready.
To jump on me right now.
He's so ready.
He's like, oh my god.
Look at this juicy support right here.
I used my sleep just to kill that guy.
Just so you know.
He runs behind us.
Oh my god.
Guys, you don't understand, I have trauma.
I've been like...
Fucking...
I've been getting fucked over by so many...
By so many Spidermans.
Like...
You don't understand.
It's...
It's not good for me.
It's not good.
I had to walk up.
Because we're down.
We're down one.
Oh my god.
I fucking...
I don't want to mess with the amazing Spiderman.
Who said I did?
I never wanted to.
Please, I don't have heals.
Please.
I don't have enough heals here.
I don't have heals.
Oh my god, he did it.
Oh my god, we did it.
You said toxin.
He deserves it.
I was trying to sleep.
Oh my god, the fucking ox.
Somebody kill the ox.
Yes.
Oh my god.
He has ult.
Do we have enough time?
I'm 76.
I don't have enough time for build ult unless...
Unless...
Oh my god.
Push cart.
Yes.
I'm trying.
Magics one.
Oh my god.
Had him.
They have a lot of ults coming in.
Oh my god.
I'm freaking out.
I'm going to stand on this.
I'm scared.
Oh.
I feel like mantis ult is more value, isn't it?
Oh, this is...
Oh, not the moon.
Oh no, he got...
I did that.
Oh my god.
Please be born again.
Not Spiderman.
No.
They did born again.
The current score is...
3, 2, 1.
Amazing Spiderman.
Time to switch things up.
It is what it is.
It is winnable, technically.
It can be.
It can be winnable.
Oh my god.
Guys, why did you have to root for Team Wavy?
Guys, do you not want me to be happy?
Damn, that's...
That's emotional manipulation.
Guys, you don't want me to be happy?
Don't you want me...
No.
Yes, that's right.
I'm gonna emotionally manipulate you guys.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna do it.
Wavy, it's time to throw.
It's time to throw.
Alright.
This is fun.
Are we actually TPing?
It didn't work last time.
Okay, he's down.
He's dead.
Let's go.
Push, push, push.
It's worth it.
Oh my god.
I fucking...
I gamed there.
I actually fucking gamed there.
Spiderman is going to be back now.
Oh god.
Madness is low.
They're all low.
I might be dead though.
I have a...
I have a magic on me.
I have no heals.
I'm gonna shield up.
Moonlight is low.
We got the point.
We can't get off point.
I need help.
Oh.
I was so low.
We just didn't have enough heals.
We can touch point.
I have ult soon.
I'm playing pretty from point.
We are undefeatable.
Nice.
I'm not gonna play on point.
She's down there.
Alright.
Guys, every time they jump, I have a little heart attack.
Spiderman behind.
Spiderman got him.
I have damage boosting you.
Starlord.
I'm backing out now.
Oh no.
I'm ulting this.
Their guy was changed.
Get changed.
Nice.
I'm at him.
At him low.
Oh.
I'm backing out.
I don't wanna.
I don't wanna get fucked over here.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Spiderman's low.
I'm cocooning.
I got him.
Oh my god.
You know.
That's everything.
That's actually.
The moon.
Yeah, that's.
Yeah, I wasn't.
I wasn't gonna live that.
Yeah, that was.
That was pretty rough.
For us.
Just.
Just be like.
Just use everything.
It's just fine.
Just.
Just use everything.
Sorry.
Get off.
If you don't swap.
I'm not buying.
I'm legit doing it.
Not that hard to understand.
Your logic pains me.
How?
How did we get here?
It's the first game.
I'm not even gonna argue with the brick wall.
The stack is already falling apart.
It's the first game.
I'll never be youtuber shroud.
At least.
The stack at least stays together.
My stack just fights each other.
I'm like not even the glue.
I'm not even the glue to hold people to get through.
I'm just.
I'm just like trying.
Trying to make it.
Nice.
Everybody is falling apart.
What do I do guys?
Oh my god.
How is he dead?
I'm okay.
Everything is okay.
I don't even want to stay close to people.
He goes.
Not the moon.
Oh my god.
I can't see anything.
No.
There's two DPS behind us.
It's okay.
I cocooned in the middle.
What's the worst that could happen?
Magic, magic one.
Oh my god.
Spiderman.
In your character.
Jeez.
Oh my god.
What happened?
I don't even know what the fuck happened.
Alright.
Alright, Lao.
Congrats, Lao.
You won your audition.
But Q times are ass.
Are ass.
Oh wait.
Congratulations, Lao.
You won your audition.
But Q times are ass.
Times are bad.
We'll call you.
Okay.
I'm sorry, Lao.
I can't.
I cannot wait 10 minutes.
For a Q time.
Oh my god.
I'm proud.
Lao, we're so...
We're so proud of you, Lao.
You won.
He is better.
Oh my god, it's so much faster.
The Q times are actually so much faster.
Huge shoutout to Lao.
Huge shoutout to Lao for...
For winning the audition.
He won.
But he lost.
He won the audition, guys.
Huge shoutout to him.
Now, reject Wavy's friend request.
Oh, because JTurtle?
I'm fine with that.
Sure.
Lao is now...
Now will be a regular tank stacker with us.
Don't worry, Lao.
Because you won the tank audition.
I will reject Wavy's...
I will reject Wavy's friend request.
Team Wavy!
No!
Justice for Wavy!
Crying for Wavy right now.
Alright, I'll play Adam.
Now it's my turn to play Adam.
He had his shot.
He didn't even know he was auditioning.
He didn't even know.
He could've...
If he knew he would give up his ult.
But he didn't even know.
It louder performs next time we audition Wavy next.
Where's the Adam DPS tech?
What's the Adam DPS tech?
People are coming up with new tech everyday.
I have no idea.
Are we playing this map?
Fucking hell!
This map again?
What is it?
Dude, there's literally...
There's tech everyday.
I can't keep up.
You mash left and right click and he attacks faster?
Is that...
It feels the same.
Like this?
Oh!
Oh yeah!
Okay.
Is that what you mean?
Like that?
Yeah.
Don't do that.
Okay, that's scary.
That's scary.
Alright.
Okay.
I should stop that.
I don't think I can keep up with that tech though.
I don't think I can...
I don't think I should try and use that tech because like...
Oh my god, he already...
Oh my god, he used the health pack.
I don't want to waste my heals because it's like...
It's so limited that like, I don't know.
That would be fast.
Oh my god, he's so low!
Okay, now I can't waste my heals though.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, we're trying our best.
Be careful, you have limited heals with this.
Oh my god!
There we go!
Oh my god.
Yeah.
I might as well...
Oh my god, okay guys.
I'm gonna go Loki.
There we go!
Here we go!
It's Loki time!
I'm so bad with Loki but we'll learn.
If we throw, we'll go Cloak and Dagger because I'm not that confident with Loki.
I'm actually like, not a Loki.
I barely play Loki.
Okay.
I gotta heal!
I'm healing!
I know my clone's healing him.
Let's go!
Let's go, do your thing!
Yippee!
You know what?
You go do your thing!
Go clones, go!
There we go.
Oh my god!
I didn't know where my clone is!
It was a hellmate!
It was actually a hellmate!
Okay.
Let me...
Alright.
There we go.
I'mma sneak.
I live!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
That was...
What a gamble!
It really was...
We got moon knighted.
What a fucking gamble!
It worked though!
He had no support.
It worked.
It actually worked.
Holy shit.
But we're dead.
But it worked!
Oh no.
We're dead.
But it worked.
Guys, we might be dead.
Oh my god.
But it didn't work.
For a sec.
Oh my god.
There's a Psylocke behind us.
Oh my god, please.
Oh shit!
Where did he come from?
He was behind!
Oh, that's a grid all up though.
That's why I didn't need me.
The Hawkeye's weak.
Guys, don't learn from my Loki plays.
I'm literally learning on the spot right now.
Hawkeye one.
Alright.
You live through this.
Know that.
There's a Psylocke behind.
I have one.
I'm low.
Oh, there is Psy.
Don't worry.
Please.
Oh, get that clone in there and heal!
Mag, mag, mag.
It's gonna work!
I'm learning on the spot!
Psylocke on me.
Oh, fuck.
Don't worry!
Oh, we're so healthy!
We're so healthy!
Where's my other clone?
Where did he go?
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, there's someone to my left!
Oh my god, who shot me?
Where's my Mantis?
Okay, I have to look at my Mantis.
There's someone on our Mantis.
There's a Hawkeye and a Psylocke.
This is fine.
He never miss.
But he might miss.
Oh my god, it's fine.
That's huge!
That's fucking huge!
See you guys!
I might be a naturally gifted Loki player as I fucking make every Loki player cry.
I could be making every Loki player cry watching me right now.
It hurts!
Guys, I'm learning as we go along!
I'm learning!
I'm doing great, guys!
I'm doing great!
Excuse me, this is a GM1 Loki.
It's understandable.
See, it's fine.
It's fine.
Right?
It's okay.
It's alright.
I'm here for all the Loki mains out there.
I'm here to represent you.
What the fuck?
He would be dead.
That's a lie.
He's so thirsty.
Alright guys, unzip.
Isn't that the little flower meme?
Guys, that's the flower meme, right?
What is that flower meme?
You're gonna let him die like that?
You want him to die?
Guys, he's thirsty!
Say what?
Alright.
There's a Captain America here.
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying my best here.
I'm trying my best in this situation.
This fucked up situation.
Woah!
Oh my god.
Oh, we got a pig.
Let's go.
Oh, there's a Captain America on me.
Here we go.
This is what Loki does to you.
You want him to fucking die?
You probably need to open up in your chat.
What does that mean?
Don't worry about it.
I'm scared, bro.
He introduced it himself.
I don't know, bro.
I just have my fucking chat open and it's telling me that.
I don't know.
Don't worry about it.
Is your chat insane or what?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I do that and then like...
It's like he's actually...
I don't know where he's shooting, but I think he's healing, right?
Don't worry, Loki.
Just pretend you're doing something, my clone.
If I also stand there and not move, they'll think I'm a clone.
This is how it works.
They'll think I'm a clone, right?
You don't know which one's the real one.
Oh my god.
Who's the real one?
They'll never know.
Okay, it's me.
It's actually me.
You know what?
Oh shit.
What?
I did that.
I killed Jay.
There we go.
It's just that easy.
That is a Loki laugh if I hear one.
See, I told you guys.
Guys.
I told you.
My Psylocke training will work.
Guys, my Psylocke training actually pulled through, chat.
It actually pulled through me playing Psylocke.
It worked out.
Jay Turtle.
How's my rank?
I do rank from eternity.
That's how it's been.
It's been...
It's been five hours.
I'm ready to see the plus 17?
Me too.
It's getting there.
I knew it, guys.
Truly pure cinema.
I started out trying to fucking play Psylocke in quick play, and then I utilized my Psylocke training for this very moment.
It's just pure cinema.
It was worth it.
That's fucking right.
A five hour long movie.
Luna?
Mantis?
Selfie Mantis?
That's fine.
Fan Psylocke?
We have a Psylocke player.
Target banning, I guess.
I just realized my volume was super low.
I don't know for how long.
I hope I was audible this entire time.
I don't know when my audio was super low.
No, my mic.
Me talking.
Oh, it was fine?
Thank God.
Okay.
Cause sometimes when I mute myself on GoXLR, it like, when I unmute myself, it goes down.
So like, that's why I'm like ah fuck.
See, I'm fucking flexible.
I can play any support, except for lowkey, but I played him last game.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
Yeah, it was like, I usually put it at 90, but then I, I when I checked it, it was on 84.
And I was like, that's not good.
That's not good.
Oh shit, my Streamlabs fucking crashed.
My Streamlabs labels.
Not the, uh...
Let me restart my session for this.
Not my actual Streamlabs.
I don't use Streamlabs cause...
Don't use Streamlabs because if you're a streamer, I suggest not using Streamlabs for OBS.
Because it takes up too much, uh...
What was it?
It takes up too much CPU.
So I just use regular.
I just use like, OBS.
Normal OBS.
Osnavy!
Thank you for gifting a sub.
Thank you, thank you.
And Kazu, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Whoa.
How do you know the government name?
Boop.
I also have a very tanky PC.
That which still struggles to fucking handle anything.
Hahaha.
Alright.
I'm a little concerned for our tanks.
Just a little bit.
Alright.
Ooh, that's a lot of tanks.
I like that.
But that wasn't me.
I just realized I wasn't the one that did those.
God, it like confused me.
I thought I was fucking dinking people like crazy.
Hahaha.
I was like, whoa, I'm fucking insane!
But it wasn't me.
When you saw it, it was your own teammate.
Oh, oh, that's interesting.
Alright.
Sure.
Let me try and build my ult, I guess.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Please hit something so I can build ult charge off of you.
I'm gonna have to ult this.
They're gonna have strange ult.
Go!
I'm so scared.
Oh my god!
Oh fucking shit, we're okay.
Oh, we're not okay.
We're...
We're not okay.
Oh my god.
We don't have our fucking...
We don't have our Starlord ult yet.
Oh, okay.
Hey, portal.
That's fine.
Oh, we're stuck here?
What the fuck?
Sounds fine.
Of course you're stuck.
Hello.
Hahaha.
I hope you're feeling inspired.
Oh.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
Is the what?
Magnus won.
Strange is asleep.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Yeah, I'm down.
Oh.
He said...
He...
Basically he was shit-talking our...
He was shit-talking our Starlord.
He was saying he's not real.
I got it, but Starlord's gonna ult after this.
Starlord...
Yeah.
We're gonna have Starlord ult.
We don't have support ults for it.
Alright.
You go Luna.
Farm that support ult.
I will let you farm it.
I believe in the dream.
You think she's gonna be able to do it?
She's getting there.
I'm letting her farm it.
She didn't get it.
She didn't get it, guys.
She didn't...
Guys, she didn't get it.
I believed.
Believing is always not the answer, guys.
Never believe again.
I literally didn't heal because I believed.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
I died.
I didn't build ult because I believed.
I actually...
I'm 10% off if you guys can live.
Oh, Magneto.
Where?
You know what?
Let me ult first, by the way.
Anytime.
I was waiting for the ult.
We are undefeatable!
I believe.
Oh, that's ours.
I always get confused which is ours.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Oh my god, I...
I'm scared.
I'm trying not to peek too much.
Please, farm that support.
Oh, we should be fine.
I slept the Magneto.
Magneto's low.
Strange one!
Damage!
Oh my god!
This is the last fight.
That's right!
Poor Mutant God.
I still hate Mutant God.
I'm joking.
Doki.
Do you know what I'm about to do, Doki?
You want to jump, don't you?
Yeah!
Then I'm going to go kidnap somebody.
I'm going to double jump into our spawn.
Oh my god.
Alright, no hands.
Why is my Magneto at the skybox with Wolverine?
No hands, let's go!
No hands mode!
No hands!
Okay, everybody.
Here's what's going to happen.
I'm going to go behind them.
I'm going to go kidnap somebody.
Double jump to the skybox.
And take them all the way to our spawn.
Get ready to kill him when I do.
It would be so funny if they're watching the stream right now.
There would just be like five people just waiting.
It would be so funny.
Where's the kidnap?
Where is it?
No hands!
Look at this, no hands!
Wow, no hands!
I got the Luna!
I'm flying!
Kill her!
Welcome.
You're welcome.
Hahaha.
No hands!
Oh my god.
Watch this.
Penny's so low.
Where?
I'm literally just...
I'm just right clicking.
I should like... get rid of my respawn.
Like, there's no reason to.
They tped?
Alright, ulting.
Oh shit, there's... oh, sorry buddy.
No, no, we're committing at this point.
Okay, well give me your rocket back then.
30 seconds, 30 seconds, our Luna died early.
To be fair, it was my fault, I didn't heal her.
Oh shit, double support ult!
Guys, are you so excited watching Rocket gameplay?
Oh my, so engaging.
Actually, it's so... I'm throwing armor.
Oh my god, so fucking engaging.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna ult and then swap off here.
I'm 20%.
He's looking for a strange ult.
That is strange.
Okay, I got...
Oh my god!
Okay, poor Beautycon, let's go!
Alright, let's go.
Oh my god, this gameplay!
Oh my god, I'm still... I'm right clicking.
I'm right clicking.
I'm trying so hard to keep you off.
Oh my god.
Jesus, Chris, how are we all still alive?
Can we help Maze?
Help Maze.
We're up one, we're up one.
Strange is half.
Strange one, strange one, strange one!
Alright guys, I'm gonna go back and swap.
Alright, it's time.
I'm done playing Rocket.
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna stop throwing now.
There's a Starlord behind us, up top, high ground.
Behind us, behind us!
Penny is like half.
Penny one, Penny one, Penny one!
Starlord, Starlord one!
There's a Starlord to our left.
Starlord's still low.
Everybody's still low.
Oh, strange one, strange one!
He was one.
I swear to god, I saw it with my own eyes.
I'm gonna ult this, I'm gonna ult this.
We can win this fight.
Penny one, Penny one, Penny one!
He keeps getting healed, what can I say?
I have my ult too, bro.
Do you want to shield that?
Oh my god.
TP time, TP time!
Guys, if you say people are one, they'll all aim at him and then he'll eventually be one.
That's the strat, that's the thing.
It's not my fault if they didn't shoot him.
If you shoot him, they're eventually one.
Oh my god, this server is lagging.
What the fuck is wrong with this server?
Behind us!
I don't think I'm getting ult here.
Last fight, oh man.
I don't have Lee's here for heals.
I slept him, I slept him!
Can I get that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Help our tanks, help our tanks!
Oh no.
D.Va is boosting you.
Starlord.
We got to stay on point, stay on point.
Starlord, Starlord, Starlord!
No!
We actually lost that?
We actually lost that!
I can't believe... I blame Rocket.
I...
I blame...
I blame Rocket.
I told you, Rocket's a curse.
Rocket!
No!
I even swapped off Rocket!
It's cause you quit Rocket.
Too little, no Rocket was...
Just swapped off Rocket after first fight.
It's a curse though.
Oh my god.
I...
It was all Rocket's fault.
I blame...
I blame Rocket.
Oh my god.
No, but we needed Manta's ult.
That's the thing.
We needed...
We needed the Manta's ult there.
Yeah, Mace is crashing.
What do you say?
He just says, hopefully you can go and lay in bed with your loving wife.
I'll still be here queuing like a loser.
Oh my god.
I don't think he's okay.
Yeah, I'm queuing.
I'm not...
I'm not a loser.
I have you guys here.
I...
Guys, I'm not a loser, right?
I'm still...
What does that say about you guys watching me queue, huh?
Guys...
Guys, if I'm a loser for queuing Marvel Rivals right now...
At 4.30 in the morning...
What does that say about you guys watching me queue at 4.30 in the morning?
That's right, we're in it together.
We're fucking in it together, chat.
We're from EU.
Also, Muta, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
For those who don't know, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I have a crippling addiction to Marvel Rivals right now.
So now I'm here on Twitch because I don't know how long it'll be until I can be okay.
Oh no, I know.
Six days.
In six days, I'll be fine.
In six days.
Yes, Wii.
You're here watching this crippling addiction.
It's like...
It's like the opposite of alcoholic anonymous.
Don't say that!
Don't say that.
I've invested too much time already.
Don't say that, chat.
I've invested way too much time on this already.
What did I hit proficiency on?
I upgraded.
Is it lowkey?
Oh my god, guys, I did it.
I got my icon.
Nice.
I got my one icon.
When do I hit lord?
I need...
Hero usage reaches 60 minutes.
Have I not played Mantis?
I still haven't played Mantis for 60 minutes yet?
That's crazy.
I thought I did.
No, he won the audition.
But queue times took 10 plus minutes.
So like...
We'll queue it out another time.
Oh, it gives points every 60 minutes.
Also, Cosmic, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, is it Ted?
Oh god, thank god, Ted.
Oh my god, he's still down there.
But it's okay.
I'm down here too.
He's...
It's okay.
We're...
I'm just...
I'm at the same level as Ted.
Which makes me feel so good about myself.
I...
I'm so happy that I'm at the same level as Ted.
Here, thank you for the 5 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Who's Remedy again?
Oh, that's the...
Scarlet Witch.
Player.
I remember her.
What if I just banrock it right now?
Oh shit, sorry.
Sorry.
The lord!
I see the...
Sorry.
I'm not even gonna apologize.
I like...
Oh, it's fine.
They're cute.
They...
They ban Scarlet too.
What?
Cute in a 3 second...
But why are you still playing on alts?
Is this his only alt?
How do they know?
I don't know.
If we pull up Marvel Rivals website...
Category on Twitch.
How would they know?
How...
That's so...
I'm on Twitch.
That's a surprise.
So many of you guys are watching my downward spiral.
Like, I didn't realize...
Versus Overwatch now is...
Marvel...
Okay.
Wait, no, that's not...
I'm not...
Sorry, I reported the wrong person.
I almost reported though.
Jesus.
I can't...
I can't even report.
He won't let me.
He won't even let me.
He won't even let me fucking report him.
Alright, I'll do it later.
Bro, what the fuck?
I'm just...
It truly is Doomer hours right now.
It truly is.
Bro, why are people so mad?
It's like everybody's stacks too.
Why are people angry?
It's actually crazy.
Oh yeah, I was supposed to put this on him.
Why is everyone so mad?
Why is...
Why are people so mad?
I'm just trying to fucking play video games.
I'm just trying...
Trying to play video games.
Just trying to play video games.
Just trying to play video games and keep our players alive.
Just still trying to play video games.
Oh, people are...
I have magic on me?
Oh, please!
Where did her cloak go?
Why is she over there?
Why is her cloak over there?
She disappeared.
Strong person.
I don't want to use my clap yet though.
Our cloak can heal our Spider-Man, right?
Nope.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, our cloak can heal our Spider-Man, right?
That's fine.
Yeah, he totally can.
Oh my god.
You're so healthy right now.
Who is he trying to ult there?
I don't...
I don't even know.
Who was that?
Okay, I'm fucking backing out from that.
That's fine.
Again!
There we go.
Yeah, that was...
That was a freaky ult right there.
I...
I hope this spider stubs his toe.
Somebody...
Somebody break his kneecaps right now.
So I can heal them.
It's not skill dip.
That's a strange one.
He needs to...
He needs to stop.
I can't...
Jarvis, break his legs.
I guess...
I guess it's not a skill dip.
I'm just tired of him jumping around.
For some reason...
Oh, just watch this game and then you know what the reason is.
Watch all the Spider-Man plays.
And you'll figure out what the reasons are.
I'm just gonna be right here.
I feel alive.
I feel so alive.
Right now.
I feel so alive right now.
I'm healing.
God.
Okay.
I'm not gonna look.
Fuck.
Jesus Christ.
There's nothing I can do.
I might as well just fucking die.
I just...
I like...
Literally just like waited there.
And then I was like, well fine.
That's cool.
I'm cool with that.
It's alright.
Goodbye, super fishy.
Where are you?
Oh my god.
Is he?
Alright, that's good.
I just saw him die like that.
Truly is crazy.
What a wild time.
Oh.
We cap it?
Nice.
That's right.
Your life...
What you did...
What your contribution here did not matter.
Remember that.
You basically wasted a Luna ult for no reason.
Remember that your contribution means nothing in this world!
You're fine.
You know, you're so fine.
I'm not even gonna move.
Oh my god.
Good job, Spider-Man.
I'm on point.
I'm staying.
I'm gonna stay.
Here I go.
Did he do it?
They're still shooting out.
Guys, I don't think he did it.
Is that...
I believe for a second, but believing...
Believing only makes you...
Believing is a lie.
Oh shit!
Who's that?
Believing's a lie.
To switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
Pure chaos.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine.
What's going on?
Where the fuck is going...
What is going on?!
I'm just...
Just trying to have a game.
What's going on?
I'm just...
I'm not even...
Trying that hard.
Okay, I am to be fair.
I am, but I'm not even like...
Like a...
What is it called?
You know like when people are like super...
Super like...
Toxic.
And...
Well, I am toxic, but like...
You know like...
You know like gaming toxic?
Like I still laugh it off if we lose.
But like...
Yeah, I'm malding.
I'm not even malding.
I'm just trying to have a nice time.
I'm still...
I'm still sweaty.
I just...
I don't like...
I'm not like super sweaty where I mostly just focus on the game.
I'm just...
I'm just trying to have a nice time.
Yeah, my malding is content.
Why are people sad?
Why people freak out?
It's just video games.
I say it as I got the...
As I have this crippling addiction...
To fucking Marvel Rises.
It's video games, but...
Also...
Also, I would be very sad...
If lose video games.
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm hearing two million sounds at the same time.
Oh my god, please.
My heals is on everybody.
Oh my god.
It's on everyone.
Please.
You have your ult as well, sir.
Oh.
We did it.
Go Spider-Man, go!
Kill!
Kill.
No, I can't stop at any time.
I can't.
I have a problem.
I'm surprised I still have a career after what I'm doing.
After my...
My third Marvel Rivals stream on Twitch.
I'm surprised I still have a career.
After the mutant hate.
There's a magic behind us.
Oh.
I have to ult this.
Oh my god.
He...
He tried to...
He snabbed into me and I got scared.
I have strange ult.
Oh my god, they're coming over.
He's coming over.
Magic's up.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
There we go.
We will follow you till the end.
Guys, it's just six more days, guys.
It's just six...
Stay strong for me for six more days.
And then we'll be back to our regular scheduled content.
I swear to god.
Six more days of this.
But it could end faster if we get the secure top 500.
That's all I'm saying.
All I'm saying is like, you guys stop cursing me.
We'll get our content back faster.
I'm so scared.
There's a magic behind me.
Please.
No.
Geez.
Wee.
We are on season...
I just won't be as obsessive.
For season...
It's actually season one.
Apparently this is season zero.
And next season is season one.
Apparently.
Alright.
That's five.
Wee.
Thanks.
Goodbye.
Never even like...
I just realized...
She's frozen.
She'll be so safe.
You know what?
I believe.
I'm not even gonna use my ult.
That's how much I believe.
Season zero?
Season zero is like the most important season.
What do you mean?
We never hit top 500 in the real season.
Just that two hard one tricks.
Wee.
Ten didn't play rocket.
I just realized.
Guys.
I just realized ten didn't play rocket.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
When I found you, but weren't for your...
Obsessed, so I'm fine watching you play.
Guys.
Guys, you still want...
For those who found me in VMR.
You guys will watch me when I do other stuff, right?
Guys, like...
Guys, I'm not just my bowl, right?
Guys, I swear.
I swear.
I swear, guys.
I am funny.
I swear.
Not just marble rivals.
I swear I'm funny.
I swear I'm funny and I can do variety.
Let's party.
Streaming.
I just wanna vibe.
Bro.
What?
Remedy, we were on the same team together.
Remedy.
We were fucking...
You were so cool when I had you on my team.
Remedy.
I don't use the bathroom.
They can fight all they want.
I'm just gonna fucking pee.
Still fighting?
Oh, they're not.
Okay.
Bro.
That's actually crazy.
Bro, what the fuck?
What the fuck is going on?
He's on...
He's there.
Alright, guys.
Round two.
Bro, Remedy was so cool when I solo queued into him.
What happened?
It was only...
48 hours.
What happened in 48 hours?
What happened?
Literally, what happened in 48 hours?
He had to play marble rivals.
That's true.
In 48 hours, Ted became...
Ted...
No, in 24 hours, Ted became a not...
He actually reformed and is not a Rocky Raccoon 1 trick anymore.
And then like...
Wait, bad magic?
What do we ban?
Hawkeye?
I don't know.
What do we ban?
Hawkeye?
Okay.
And then like, in 48 hours, Remedy...
Remedy changed.
He was so cool on my team.
Like, we won with Remedy.
We won with Scarlet Witch.
We won like 2 or 3 games with Scarlet Witch.
On my team.
And then he just...
Something happened.
He absorbed Ted's team.
Bro, I even won with the Scarlet Witch.
Someone edit the squad tag.
Yeah, it actually changed.
War changes people.
Something snapped, yeah.
Something happened in between those 48 hours.
I'm just here to...
Wait, isn't that guy...
Wasn't he the guy that went...
Captain America?
Isn't that him?
Wait, isn't that the portal guy?
Wait, that's the portal guy!
That's him!
It's Joan!
It's the portal guy!
It's the guy I don't remember you!
That's him from yesterday.
4...
3...
2...
1!
TP!
That was him!
He was the fucking portal guy!
That is him!
I'm wrecked!
It is him!
I had a similar experience.
Oh wait, we didn't ban Bruce Banner.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh my god.
Zerk.
I have Iron Man on me.
I mean not Iron Man, Hulk.
Hulk asleep?
Oh no!
Please!
It's so scary!
I have to reload!
I'm only solo healing right now.
I'm looking up for a while.
Oh my god.
I have to solo heal this!
And it's so hard to fucking heal Iron Man!
When he's fighting a stupid Iron Man 1v1!
Jesus Christ, this Iron Man 1v1 is so dumb.
What the fuck?
Is it worth ulting?
I don't think so.
Oh my god!
Remedy is not playing Scarlet!
He wants to win!
He actually...
Holy shit!
What happened to all my...
Oh my god!
What are my Qs?
I'm gonna ult this.
Actually, what are my Qs?
This is actually crazy.
Hulk has ult.
I have ult.
Hulk on me.
Don't wake up!
Please!
Hulk 1!
Oh my god!
Did I stop his ult?
His ult?
It's Hulk.
I feel like I stopped it, but I'm not sure.
I'm gonna cut him.
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
There's a Hulk behind us.
He's 1.
He's asleep too.
Oh, he was so close!
I'm not gonna look.
There's an Iron Man behind us.
He's low.
The stupid Hulk!
Hulk is low.
Hulk is 1.
I got punted.
You have no supports.
Oh my god!
He's going in!
I was gonna ult if he stayed there.
Weirdo.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Oh, I thought that was magic move.
For some reason.
I'll ult this.
Hulk 1!
There's an Iron Man behind here!
He's looking for ult.
Oh my god!
I slept him!
Hulk 1!
He was so low.
Nevermind.
Hulk half!
What?!
What happened?
There's a map change!
What the fuck?!
Oh my god!
What the fuck was that eye?!
I couldn't see the ult!
The ult didn't hit!
He's asleep.
Oh my god, please.
There's a Hulk harassing us on the backline.
He's asleep, he's asleep.
Oh my god!
Did you just got sniped?!
The eye fucked me up!
The eye like...
Cause I heard half of it, so I was like, oh it's gone.
And then like...
Oh my god!
You swap, I swap.
He wasn't even...
It wasn't...
Word?
I didn't think...
Do you really think he's gonna swap?
I'm gonna leave him.
Damn.
There's no such thing as time.
There's no such thing as time in Marvel Rivals.
It's just grind.
It's all about the grind, baby.
It's all about the grind.
I'm not gonna fall off this time.
I'm scared.
This Ironman vs Ironman is so fucking stupid, dude.
Not gonna lie.
I'm getting...
I'm gonna ult this.
And win this fight.
Oh man, no more ults.
Hulk on me, Hulk!
We can leave him, Bruce Banner.
We can leave him there.
Nah.
Oh, he did...
He did do the gentleman's agreement.
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
He actually believed!
That's so sad!
Ironman behind.
Yeah, Ironman has ult.
He's looking for it.
Oh, it's only me supporting.
He's so low, the Ironman.
Oh my god.
He lost hope in humanity.
He actually lost hope.
Oh, they used rocket ult.
He actually...
Now he hates the world.
Now he'll never believe anymore.
He'll never believe anymore.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Wait, what is he doing?
Remedy's just...
AMK!
I got confused.
I thought he was gonna move.
I got so confused.
I was like, why is he not moving?
Oh my god.
I legitimately thought he was gonna move.
We could back up and kite it.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm backing up.
I'm gonna win it.
I'm gonna ult this.
You guys are all low.
Oh shit, nice.
Let's see who does two picks.
Let's push up.
I'm on...
Magnil's half.
Magnil's one.
Or low.
I have him.
He's one.
That poor Bruce Banner.
Why are you so low?
Oh my god.
This is scary.
He's low, he's low.
Alright.
Woah.
Wait, is that huge?
I can't tell.
I can't see anything.
There's so many things going on!
Oh, I don't wanna get again.
I'm gonna farm leaves off of him.
What's going on?
Who's that?
Oh no!
You have no supports.
What is that?
I was like...
Oh my god, wait a minute.
That sounds really close.
I was like, wait a minute.
That sounds too close.
I slept him.
I melted my eye.
Oh, fuck.
What are you doing?
Loki, Loki.
Alright.
Nice.
He's behind...
That's like...
He's behind me, isn't he?
Alright, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
The audio's good in this game.
It's really good.
Honestly.
Which is crazy, because I'm just thinking like...
It's been four plus years.
What?
Can't...
Two points.
Two fucking points!
Literally two points!
I died!
So close.
So close, yet so far.
Oh my god.
We were so close, and yet so far.
Okay.
Okay, the Ironman versus Ironman fight was actually so fucking stupid to watch.
The worst part is that the...
I have to...
I don't want to watch it, because it's so stupid.
But I have to, because I have to heal him.
I have to heal the fucker.
They look like they're just...
Yeah, it's actually so dumb.
It's just two flies just be like...
We have to watch it together, too.
That shit was so fucking dumb.
I'm here from the group...
No, it's just...
Guys, it's just six days.
Or...
Guys, like I said, it could be sooner.
If we get to...
It could be sooner.
We could get top...
We could secure top 500.
Guys.
Guys, we could...
We could get it sooner.
Where's Remedy?
Where Remedy go?
No.
Where did Remedy go?
Remedy.
Alright, we have a Bruce player.
We have Hootie.
Hootie on Mars.
Oh my god.
He doesn't want to do it all again.
Oh no, we didn't get the...
Oh, imagine if we did.
He's like, I don't want to play Iron, man.
He's just like...
Please.
I don't want to do this all over again.
He's ironed out, man.
What's my main?
Just support.
Oh shit, they did it.
Shoutout to you guys.
Alright, here we go.
I'm just a support main.
Cause like...
I don't like making it easy for myself.
I don't...
I don't like...
I don't... You know what?
I hate it when it's too easy, so I decided to become a support player.
Key quotes.
Support.
You know, I just hate fun.
That's really it.
No, actually no, I'm not a tank main.
I'm not a tank main, so I...
So like, tank mains hate fun.
Tank mains just want to get beat up in the frontline.
And I just like watching it happen.
Support is one of the... I feel like support is one of the hardest.
Look at I am.
Hi, ammo.
Just cause like...
Oh.
Okay.
Who do you seed?
Oh.
Goodbye...
Goodbye, Romasin.
We're just gonna play it just in case.
You know?
Just in case.
Just in case he's like...
He comes back after...
I don't know.
I don't believe.
I don't believe that, you know...
He like does...
He like actually is for real, real.
Hey, it's even now.
It's even now.
You know, anything can happen.
Anything fucked up can happen, I believe.
Alright.
Is that a minute yet?
Yep.
I fucking knew it!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it.
I never believed.
I wasn't gonna troll.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
Never believed.
Always be pessimistic.
I'm all this in.
That's fucking right.
That's huge.
Nice.
There's a Hulk behind us, sleeping.
He's a Frozen now, too.
Strange has ult here.
I knew it.
I knew he would come back and then...
What if I just get crushed right now?
I could have just got...
I actually almost got crushed right there.
Oh my god, it was right there.
That's why you gotta...
That's why you have to always play as if they'll come back and fuck you over.
Alright, here we go.
That's fine.
You're so healthy.
Strange is looking for an ult.
There's a Hulk.
Oh, Hulk is one.
Hulk is one.
I got Hulk.
Oh my god, he's trying.
Oh my god!
Manta's one shot.
I'm scared.
I have to reload.
Oh my god!
Fuck that guy in particular!
Manta's low.
Got her.
He wasn't low, I lied.
But he doesn't know that.
He killed him thinking she was low.
One more, one more.
But he didn't know that.
He thought he was low.
I told you.
You always stay there one.
So don't poke.
That's the strat.
You can Manta's ult first.
That's what...
Did you say Strangel?
You know, I...
That's you?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
This is it.
But why?
Because this guy...
Wait, we just used both support ults.
GG.
Hehehehehe.
Damn.
Huge ult.
He's playing fucking Ranked at 5 in the morning.
Of course he's lost it.
I've lost it since I started streaming.
See that ult?
Huge ult.
Huge fucking ult.
Honestly, I would have not been surprised if he actually threw us off the cliff.
Yeah.
Tyloc behind us.
Tyloc won't.
Oh.
Hulk?
Oh, nevermind.
He was...
Uh, change TP.
I got it.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
It's like reflex now.
It's an actual reflex now.
I play this way too much.
Oh, I thought...
Oh, it's Joe!
Fuck you, Joe!
I lost too many games with you!
Actually, fuck you, Joe.
Was that Emo?
Eat it!
Poor Joe.
I'm gonna play this.
He's lost me too many games.
I'm dead.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
She's surviving.
Please be...
I'm sorry to tell you this, but Jeff is not meta.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, buddy.
Jeff is like...
Is not it.
Oh my god!
The stupid fucking map!
Fucking...
Oh, nice.
Oh, I think we might need a backup here.
I don't know.
It's winnable.
Yep, it's not.
Sorry, buddy.
You gotta find a Jeff 1 trick.
No Jeff players here.
This is...
This is eternally GM 1 lobby.
You gotta find a Jeff 1 trick if you want a Jeff gameplay.
This is Jeff...
Oh shit!
I looked at my chat and she's dead.
Like, what happened?
Oh, Hulk is low.
Hulk is 1.
He's getting healed.
Hulk is off.
I froze her.
Oh my god, how is he...
Wait, Hulk is so low.
We need Mantis ult first if we need it.
Fuck this lamp in general.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Oh, nice.
There's a Hulk turret right?
Yeah, he's froze.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I didn't see.
I am ready to put on a show.
We gotta play on point if we can.
Oh my god.
Let's use this to heal Junk.
Oh, I'm ulting.
Oh my god, I'm dancing!
I'm dancing!
Oh, is he okay?
Oh, I'm scared.
So I'm not gonna look at him.
Why does everybody fucking hate me today?
Yo,
somebody give me a NPC.
Mace, Hoodie, Doki, any of you.
I'm a billionaire, I'll buy you a new PC, bro.
Oh my god, we got Eternity back.
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
I'm sorry, Joan.
I'm fucking avoiding you.
You creeped me too many times.
Did you guys know there's only like 300 to 400 players in Eternity?
I know it's crazy to see that.
That I'm like, no.
Should we keep going?
We go until we lose.
Let's do it.
Alright, guys.
Now that...
Okay, I can do it with Drake.
Alright, now that...
Mace is gone.
But...
I believe in Drake and I.
We play until we lose.
I like how I said that.
And then...
And then Mace disappeared.
That's actually hilarious.
Alright.
Wait, actually...
Oh no, Lau's gone.
Oh wait, Lau's gone, alright.
Wait, Mac got Eternity back.
Oh my god, look at that!
I fucking always believed in you, Mac.
Yeah, my gold- wait, wavy?
Alright, let's see.
Wait, wait.
Where is wavy?
Has he been doing okay?
Oh.
GG's, miss.
GG's.
I don't know.
I don't know if he's been doing okay.
Do we adopt wavy?
He's being okay.
Oh, he got off.
Did he get off after we beat him?
He was not okay.
Alright.
He- is he okay?
What about remedy?
Guys, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know what remedy is.
I'm gonna add remedy because it was funny.
Who's half-ish?
Who is he?
Did I add this guy?
Oh, is it because of the auditions?
I like- did he get eternity and then fucking send me a friend request because he wanted to audition?
I-
Because I said, let's go.
Let's fucking audition.
Invite him.
You need more tanks.
I thought the job was finished.
What, you wanna get back in here, mace?
You went back online.
Wait, actually I don't even know if he went offline and then came back.
I don't know if he's like- I sent a call to action tweet.
We just invite all of the tank players.
Audition to be- to be our tank player.
No, he went off.
Alright.
That's why we were queued up anyway.
Okay.
Job's not done, guys.
We can't- we always end on a loss.
Job's not done.
Yeah, it's like American Idol, but for tanks, basically.
Oh, did- did that guy?
Was it with us?
Oh, I fucking- Oh, sorry.
I fucking got him off the game.
He lost against me and he never came back.
He never came back.
That poor man.
I love you.
Alright, nice.
I made him log off.
I def- oh hey, Max here!
We technically papped the team again.
I made two people log off.
Oh.
No.
He's actually just sitting like, dude, fuck this map.
Mack and Kendrick Lamar, don't fight.
Don't fight.
Please stop fighting.
Please don't fight, Kendrick Lamar and Mack.
Please don't fight.
The reason why our stack originally broke up is that these two were fighting.
These two.
No.
No!
That happened three hours ago.
And then I told Drake, I was like, I'll do one game and if we win, we'll keep going.
I was like, if not, I'm just gonna solo queue because they were fighting each other.
You're calm now, right?
Why is everyone beefing each other?
I have no idea.
Oh my god, I fucking hate this map.
Kendrick Lamar did not have a good time.
No, if I lose, I'm still Eternity.
I have a buffer.
I have a buffer right now.
I'm Eternity now.
For now, again.
Another day on Eternity.
Until I lose it again.
It's alright.
We'll just adopt another tank player next- not tomorrow, tomorrow I'm resting from- Actually, my cramp's gone, but I don't want to risk it, you know?
I don't want to risk it.
At least, like, Drake vacated, won't complain about the lack of orbs because, like, they're on support.
I don't think they need it.
Groot!
No!
He said I am Groot for one last time.
I'm trying to keep you up, Groot.
Oh my god.
I need to put down Groot.
This Chunky boy needs fucking heals.
This Chunky boy.
This Chunky boy needs to be kept up no matter what.
Chunky boy, live.
Please.
Chunky boy, just live.
Oh my god, Chunky boy did it.
He's Grooting.
He's fucking actually- Okay.
Okay.
Okay, my Chunky boy, you live.
You live.
Alright.
She's so ready!
Why?
Why didn't you just dance?
You just live.
We don't even have a- Why?
Why did she- Why did she not dance the zone?
Like, I don't understand.
Wait.
Mantis, can you push guard?
I'm gonna build ult.
Alright, my turn to build ult.
Alright.
I am Groot.
I'm Grooting.
No, the group brainwashed is hitting right now.
It's absolutely hitting.
They have strange ults.
Oh my god.
I'm alive.
Oh, he's so low.
We're even.
No!
Nice!
Oh, not nice.
I'm 5% off.
Ult.
You guys can live.
I got it.
Come on.
I'm mad.
I am Groot.
I am- I'm leaving.
Groot's leaving.
No!
Goodbye, Wakanda.
Goodbye.
What the fuck is that portal?
What are you gonna do there?
Kill me?
Oh, not me.
Him though.
Oh my god.
Oh, Groot, please.
Oh, he's so low, Magneto.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking- We're up one.
We should push up.
I'm fucking strange.
Strange.
Strange on cart.
Alright, nice.
Oh, we can Mantis ult first.
Oh my god.
What if I just close the door?
How do I close this door?
Oh, I almost closed the door against her Mantis.
That would be so fucking bad.
Oh my god!
That tree blocked me!
Oh my-
I am stuck!
Oh my god, it was my own tree too!
Yeah, because I was dead.
That was a good ult.
I am Groot.
I am...
The group reroll is hitting right now.
I don't think Max will miss.
Unless he's just- He's tweaking right now.
He's actually- He fucking unlocked his inner Wakanda.
He unlocked his inner Wakanda.
Because I remember like, Toast made a tweet and he was like, Is it bad if I save for Wakanda?
Oh, I don't have ult for this.
I don't know if you guys saw that fucking tweet from Toast.
They're all so low!
They're all- Trina's one!
Trina's one!
Trina's one.
Support low too.
That's fine.
That's so fine.
I'm damage boosting this.
I'm damage boosting.
Trina's one.
Trina's solo.
Nice.
Oh god, the first- Wait, I'll read you guys Toast's tweet.
I saw that and I was like, what the fuck, Toast?
I'll read you what he wrote.
He was like, He was like, Fellas, is it socially acceptable for a middle-aged Asian man to yell Wakanda forever after he gets a triple kill as Black Panther on Marvel Rivals?
I was just like, what the fuck?
He earned it.
I was just like, what the fuck, Toast?
Okay, but it was a triple kill on Black Panther.
Like, that's impressive.
Like, as a middle-aged Asian man, I confirm, it is acceptable.
If I adopt another tank player, I'll keep going.
Auditions are open yet again.
Marvel Rivals, sponsor me.
I have- whoa.
I'm a degenerate grinder.
Oh, what up, though?
Oh.
Oh, I hope they're okay.
Hmm, let's bet.
I looked at the Mantis and I died.
I looked at him.
What happened?
He retouched.
He got the Scrooge.
I got- I got died of Black Panther.
Like I said, he got the Scrooge and then Black Pan- and then he walked past Black Panther.
Like, what the fuck?
I thought he- I don't know.
I thought- I legitimately thought he- You know, he- there's a Black Panther on our Mantis.
Can I throw a Frozen too?
We're even.
Oh.
That's scary.
Oh, that's- Oh, helper!
Helper group.
You're full of Hawkeye.
Hawkeye's one?
They should still have Strangelord here and Hawkeye.
Alright.
Oh, I'm scared.
Can you top me off real quick, Mantis?
I'm so scared.
I'm ulting this one, please.
Oh my god, I'm damage boosting?
I'm damage boosting.
They still have Strangelord.
Oh my god, this is- he's Grooting.
Oh, our group looked at it too.
Our group was looking at him in disappointment.
He was not happy.
Did you see our group just looked at it?
He was like, sir, that happened.
He was just like, oh man.
We actually lost that.
I need to be topped off.
The more is half?
Oh my god, if you can ult to stabilize.
Alright.
You're down a Luna.
You're down two.
I can- if you live, I can ult.
No!
Oh my god, I guess I'll try and live on cart.
Oh my god, I just don't want to get one-shot.
I just don't want to get one-shot.
I just don't want to get one-shot by fucking Hawkeye.
I'm fucking trying my best to not get one-shot by Hawkeye.
That's why I was like running back and forth because like, Hawkeye's the only character that can one-shot me.
So I was like, I ain't letting that happen.
There's a rocket behind.
He has ult.
Hawkeye's the only character that can one-shot me out of all- that's why I was like going back and forth.
I was like, just don't kill me.
Just don't kill me.
That was a very sad eye.
No, it was.
It was 100% an incredibly sad eye.
I was not having it.
Oh my god, he's back.
The Black Panther's back.
Black Panther's one.
Oh, I rooted away.
I think we can kite this.
Oh shit, that's huge.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I have ult in five.
Let's go!
They can still TP.
They might TP this.
I'll listen for it.
It doesn't sound like they are.
Whoa!
He's gonna groove.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I'm gonna ult you here.
Oh my god, we did it!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he rooted.
He actually rooted.
Alright, someone do exclamation point Nuna, why I don't do the tech.
And why you don't see people do the tech anymore.
Someone.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they can't work together.
Oh my god, I'm so...
But what if we do one more...
Oh my god, I'm so proud of them.
I'm so proud.
They did it.
They actually worked together.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we can't end on a win.
We can't, we can't.
That's not how we do it here.
Come on, Drake, big hater.
Come on, one more...
One more game on the road.
Come on.
How long has it been bugged?
It's been bugged since the second day.
People don't notice it because...
We are up though.
We are up.
Oh my god.
Fucking ignore this though.
This is where we started.
No, this is where we started.
Things were great and then things started not being so great.
Guys, I'm sorry to tell you but Drake's a fucking... Kendrick Lamar is a fucking quitter.
I'm sorry, guys.
So positive.
Tomorrow won't be... Actually, I don't know.
Maybe I'll play a little bit off stream tomorrow.
I don't know.
Tomorrow I may or may not... Actually, no.
I'm not going to... I don't want you guys to camp on my chat.
Guys, I'm not going to let you guys camp in my chat so I'm just going to say tomorrow I'm not going to be streaming Marvel Rivals.
I'm going to rest my hand a little bit.
My left hand.
My right hand is okay.
Usually it's your right hand.
I'm going to rest my left hand for tomorrow.
GGs, everybody.
For those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
Right now, I have a very crippling addiction to Marvel Rivals.
That's why I'm here on Twitch at the moment.
So please follow me on YouTube if you subscribe to me.
That's great!
Marvel Rivals, devs!
For once in my life, I have more viewers than Necros.
Where's my...
Sorry.
All I'm saying is that I could also be a sponsor too.
Real though.
For once in my life.
You're already addicted.
You're literally playing the game for...
But all I'm saying is it would be great to sponsor me before...
If you sponsor me, I'll stay after season zero.
Anyway, I do want to get paid for my addiction.
Like, I'm literally doing this for free.
They already got me.
They already fucking got me.
Yeah, okay.
Alright, here's the deal.
But if you sponsor me, I'll buy skins.
I'll actually spend money.
I haven't spent a single dollar in Marvel Rivals yet.
I'm free to play, baby.
I'm literally a free to play warrior.
I haven't spent any fucking money.
I'm here to free to play.
I will shill your skins if you sponsor me.
Got a Marvel Rivals.
All I'm saying, you know where the money's at.
I would shill your skins so fucking hard.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for watching.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching me.
I swear, I'm variety.
Guys, please don't leave me because of Marvel Rivals.
Dragoons.
Dragoons, I swear to God.
Dragoons, please.
I'm not trying to kill my career right now.
Just six more days.
Six more days.
Anyway, guys.
Things I want to personally shill.
I do have several.
If you want to support me via other means.
Follow me on Twitter.
I usually tweet out when I'm going to go live on Twitch.
If you want to support me via other means, I have an Android.
I do have an Android that you can pre-order.
For those who are new here and want to see what an Android looks like.
Where's an Android?
Yay!
From Good Smile.
I have an Android.
Yes, that's me.
That's my older skinsuit.
And if we have enough orders for an Android, we might get an Android of this skinsuit.
Of the Bounty Hunter skinsuit.
Anyway, other than that, I also have other things to shill.
I have a custom PC case.
Apparently, it might get restocked.
I know it says sold out.
But apparently, I don't know.
Or my manager lied to me.
But I was like, is it sold out?
And they're like, no, they're planning on restocking it.
But I do have PC keycaps.
Custom PC cases.
Desk mat.
Charms.
Wall scroll.
What else?
My GamerStuff code is DokiBird for 10% off.
I actually drank GamerStuff literally before this stream.
That's why I'm alive right now.
What else?
I think that's really it.
Anyway, guys, thank you all for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Pause your check-in up and around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!